jetzt die Reaktion des
Oppositionsführers von Friedrich Merz
für die cdu/cs-fraktion Frau Präsidentin
lassen Sie mich zunächst namens der
cdu/csu Bundestagsfraktion ein Wort des
Danke sagen für ihre
anteilnehmenden Worte für unseren
verstorbenen Kollegen
zero-hand Worte die sie zu Beginn
unserer heutigen Sitzung gesprochen
haben
ich möchte in diesem dank einschließen
den Vorsitzenden der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion Herr Kollege
Mütze nicht sie haben mir im Namen ihrer
Fraktion und der Familie
unseres verstorbenen Kollegen und uns
einen sehr persönlichen Brief
geschrieben und ihr Mitgefühl
ausgedrückt das ist ein guter
parlamentarischer Umgang ich danke Ihnen
auch persönlich dafür herzlich und auch
denen aus anderen Fraktionen die uns
dieses Mitgefühl zum Ausdruck gebracht
haben herzlichen Dank dafür
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen unsere heutige Aussprache
über die Regierungserklärung des
Bundeskanzlers steht ganz im Schatten
der Nachrichten und der Bilder über die
schweren Erdbeben in der Türkei und in
Syrien betroffen ist eine große Region
von rund 25 Millionen Einwohnern in der
bereits über 8.000 Menschen ihr Leben
verloren haben
unsere Gedanken sind bei den Familien
auch bei vielen Familien die in
Deutschland leben auch hier in Berlin
leben die um ihre Angehörigen trauern
und bei den Familien die nun selbst bei
Schnee und eisiger Kälte in den
betroffenen Regionen um ihr Leben
kämpfen
Herr Bundeskanzler wird teilen das
Mitgefühl dass sie im Namen der
Bundesregierung ausgesprochen haben und
wir bieten Ihnen ausdrücklich an dass
wir jede Unterstützung geben wenn es
etwa darum geht jetzt schnell weitere
Hilfen zu ermöglichen und zum Beispiel
Haushaltsmittel bereitgestellt werden
sollen für die betroffenen Regionen und
für die betroffenen Menschen
diese Bilder aus der Türkei und aus
Syrien erreichen uns zu einem Zeitpunkt
zu dem die russischen Angriffe in der
Ukraine wieder zunehmen und zu einem
Zeitpunkt zu dem mit einer
großangelegten Offensive der russischen
Armee um den ersten Jahrestag des Kriegs
herum gerechnet werden muss
es gibt unverändert in diesem Haus einen
großen wenn auch leider nicht
uneingeschränkten Konsens darüber dass
dieser Krieg ein russischer
Angriffskrieg ist der durch nichts aber
auch durch gar nichts zurechtfertigen
ist ein Krieg
ein Krieg der im Gegenteil
das bleibt was er von Anfang an war
nämlich einen verbrecherischer
Angriffskrieg gegen ein Land von dem
keinerlei Bedrohung ausging und das
allein deshalb angegriffen wird und
wurde weil es sich der Unterwerfung
unter einen imperialen russischen
Herrschaftsanspruch nicht beugen will
betone das hier noch einmal so deutlich
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen weil wir
uns außerhalb der Ukraine und dann eben
auch hier in Deutschland nicht daran
gewöhnen dürfen dass dieser Krieg nun
schon fast ein Jahr stattfindet und
möglicherweise noch sehr viel länger
dauert
wir müssen und der Bundeskanzler sie
haben das in ihrer Regierungserklärung
am 27 februar und mehrfach seitdem und
heute wieder immer wieder richtig gesagt
wir müssen dem Land weiter helfen
humanitär finanziell und eben auch
militärisch
und ich möchte mit ihnen allen zusammen
meine Damen und Herren heute nur hoffen
dass wir nicht eines Tages aus der
Rückschau sagen müssen das war zu wenig
und das war zu spät lassen wir uns
hoffen dass wir dies nicht sagen müssen
und ich will das hier sehr offen
ansprechen denn es ist doch in diesem
Zusammenhang eines nicht zu übersehen
große Teile der sogenannten zeitenwände
die sie am 27 februar von dieser Stelle
aus beschrieben haben große Teile dieser
zeitenwände finden bisher in Deutschland
weitgehend auf dem Papier statt
richtig ist dass Deutschland moderne
Luftabwehrsysteme und moderne adlerie
geliefert hat richtig ist aber auch dass
Deutschland bis zum Schluss gebremst und
gezögert hat bis vor zwei Wochen und
endgültig die Entscheidung getroffen
wurde der Ukraine auch moderne
Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzer zu
liefern und jetzt die Auslieferung wird
erneut einige Wochen wenn nicht Monate
dauern und mit der Ausbildung der
Soldaten aus der Ukraine und mit der
Instandsetzung der Fahrzeuge wird erst
jetzt in diesem Tagen begonnen
wohlgemerkt einige Tage bevor wir mit
der nächsten Offensive der russischen
Streitkräfte rechnen müssen und der
Bundeskanzler in hohem Maße verstörend
sind in diesem Zusammenhang dann
Äußerungen
ihrer Außenministerin wenn sie vor zwei
Wochen vor der Parlamentarischen
Versammlung des Europarates in Straßburg
wörtlich den Satz spricht auf Englisch
wie sie meinte sprechen zu müssen we are
fighting war against rascher das waren
ihre Worte vor Werburg und sie dürfen
sich nicht wundern sie dürfen sich nicht
wundern wenn ein solcher Satz
rasende Verbreitung findet in den
russischen Medien und damit Teil wird
der russischen Propaganda sie dürfen
sich darüber nicht wundern wenn sie
solche ungedachten
[Musik]
und es bleibt absolut inakzeptabel der
Bundeskanzler dass die Bundesregierung
bisher aus dem hier gemeinsam
beschlossenen sogenannten Sondervermögen
praktisch keine Bestellung aufgegeben
und keine Ausschreibung veröffentlicht
hat das gilt vor allem auch für die
Bestellung von Munition erinnern Sie
sich daran wie sie uns hier unter
Zeitdruck gesetzt haben die schnell das
alles gehen musste mit der Änderung des
Grundgesetzes nur um mal eine Zahl zu
nennen die Ukraine braucht in einem Tag
so viel Munition wie in Deutschland in
sechs Monaten hergestellt werden könnte
die Firmen die Fahrzeuge liefern könnten
die Firmen die Munition produzieren
könnten melden sich mittlerweile
reihenweise bei uns und unseren
Wahlkreis Abgeordneten und beklagen sich
darüber dass sie keine Aufträge bekommen
dass die Zahlungsziele nicht eingehalten
werden und damit keine
Planungssicherheit
seitens der Bundesregierung besteht Herr
Bundeskanzler so kann man auch mit den
Bündnis Verpflichtungen nicht umgehen
das geht nicht was sie hier machen
wenn der Bundesverteidigungsminister
heute auch nicht da sein kann so will
ich es trotzdem an seine Adresse sagen
wir trauen ihm deutlich mehr zu als
seiner amtsvorgängeerin aber er muss
dann auch jetzt schnell das gesamte
Beschaffungswesen in seinem
Verantwortungsbereich ändern damit diese
Missstände abgestellt werden und wir
schnell bestellen können meine Damen und
Herren anders wird es nicht gehen
die Erdbeben in der Türkei und in Syrien
und der Krieg in der Ukraine dürften in
den nächsten Wochen noch einmal zu einer
erheblichen Größe erheblich größeren
Zahl von Flüchtlingen und Asylbewerbern
in Europa und damit auch in Deutschland
führen meine Damen und Herren damit das
klar ist wir können und wir wollen auch
in den nächsten Monaten so vielen
Menschen wie möglich die in Not geraten
sind helfen aber zusätzlich zu den über
eine Millionen Flüchtlingen aus der
Ukraine die wir in Deutschland schon
aufgenommen haben kommen seit dem Herbst
des letzten Jahres vermehrt Flüchtlinge
und Asylbewerber aus Syrien aus dem Irak
aus Afghanistan und aus weiteren Ländern
des Mittleren Ostens in vielen
Landkreisen Städten und Gemeinden
unseres Landes sind die
Aufnahmekapazitäten aber mittlerweile
erschöpft
und wenn selbst Bürgermeister aus
Gemeinden Städten und Landkreisen die
der Grünen Partei angehören jetzt
lautstark um Hilfe rufen dann können Sie
Herr Bundeskanzler nicht darauf
verweisen dass die bundesinnenministerin
jetzt ein zweites Mal einen
flüchtlingsgipfel einberuf der erste war
schon erfolgreich und sie Frau fäser
sind mit ihrem Kopf offensichtlich schon
mehr in Wiesbaden als in Berlin
unterwegs das ist eine Aufgabe der
Bundeskanzler nein das ist war das mögen
sie nicht gerne hören aber es ist so der
Bundeskanzler das ist jetzt eine Aufgabe
für Sie für Sie persönlich
sie müssen jetzt zu einem
flüchtlingsgipfel unter ihrer Führung
mit konkreten Maßnahmen einladen
insbesondere damit den Städten und
Gemeinden in Deutschland wirksam
geholfen wird und nicht wieder erneut
ein solcher flüchtlingsgipfel wie im
letzten Jahr im Oktober ohne jede
Ergebnisse verbracht wird
nun beschreiben sie in ihrer
Regierungserklärung sehr wortreich eine
gemeinsame europäische Asylpolitik und
einen besseren Schutz der
EU-Außengrenzen meine Damen und Herren
das ist unsere Meinung schon seit langem
aber warum aber warum erwähnen Sie warum
erwähnen sie in ihrer
Regierungserklärung mit keinem Wort die
Vorschläge der schwedischen
Ratspräsidentschaft zu einer zukünftigen
Asylpolitik der Europäischen Union sie
loben dankenswerterweise die
kommissionspräsidentin aber zur
europäischen Ratspräsidentschaft sagen
sie hier gar nichts insbesondere zu den
fünf Vorschlägen die die europäische
Ratspräsidentschaft sehr konkret gemacht
hat unter anderem alle Instrumente voll
auszuschöpfen in der Entwicklungshilfe
in der weservergabe im Handel und in den
diplomatischen Beziehungen das wird mit
einer Handbewegung seitens ihrer
Innenministerin vom Tisch gewischt und
wird noch nicht einmal zur Diskussion
gestellt weil sie es nicht wollen Herr
Bundeskanzler so wird europäische
Asylpolitik nicht gelingen wenn sie so
weitermachen
und Sie können dabei sie können dabei
auch nicht auf die Europäische Union
allein verweisen Asylpolitik findet auch
in den Mitgliedstaaten stattfindet auch
hier stattfindet übrigens auch in der
Stadt Berlin statt der von ihrer Partei
geführte Berliner Senat hat vor Monaten
durch Beschluss
aufgehört irgendwelche Rückführungen
Abschiebungen aus Berlin vorzunehmen das
abschiebeterminal am Berliner Flughafen
ist geschlossen worden sie machen keine
sie machen keine Rückführungen und keine
Ausweisungen und Abschiebungen mehr aus
Berlin und selbst diejenigen die
Straftaten begangen haben müssen wenn
sie erstmal in Berlin sind nicht
befürchten noch abgeschoben zu werden
sie können das nicht alles in Brüssel
Abladen das sind Entscheidungen die sie
hier in Deutschland führen müssen und
insbesondere in der Stadt Berlin
getroffen werden müssen
sie verbinden die Asylpolitik mit der
Notwendigkeit einer neuen
Einwanderungspolitik in die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland meine Damen
und Herren wir werden das Thema hier
noch sehr viel ausführlicher diskutieren
als es uns heute möglich ist vielleicht
nur so viel wir haben heute schon eine
große Zahl von Flüchtlingen und
Einwanderern in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland und sie wollen jetzt noch
einmal mehrere hunderttausend zusätzlich
in das Land einladen und hier zu
arbeiten und zu leben meine Damen und
Herren aber wir brauchen für weitere
Einwanderung in Deutschland Kitas wir
brauchen schulen wir brauchen
Krankenhäuser wir brauchen vor allen
Dingen Wohnungen dieses Land ist auf
eine zusätzliche Einwanderung in der
Größenordnung wie sie sie planen Herr
Bundeskanzler in der gesamten
Infrastruktur nicht vorbereitet ich
mache Ihnen einen anderen Vorschlag ich
mache Ihnen einen anderen Vorschlag
schöpfen Sie doch einmal zunächst die
Potenziale aus die wir im albertsmarkt
in Deutschland selber haben und ich gebe
Ihnen dazu eine Zahl die ich selber als
ich sie nachgeschaut habe selbst nicht
glauben wollte im Jahr 2021 jetzt hören
sie in Augenblick zu bevor sie sich so
künstlich erregen hier im Jahr 2021
Zahlen vom Jahr 2022 haben wir noch
nicht sind 440.000
ältere Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in den Vorruhestand gegangen
das ist rund die Hälfte der Rentnerinnen
und Rentner die in diesem Jahr in den
Ruhestand gegangen sind
Öl davon sind abschlagsfrei in die
Rentenversicherung gegangen sie haben
mal angekündigt dass sie daran was
ändern wollen sie haben nichts geändert
daran es bleibt dabei dass in ihrer
Fraktion und ihrer Partei davon geträumt
wird dass die Vorruhestandsregelungen
weiter fortgesetzt werden können mit
dieser Art der Rentenpolitik werden sie
das Problem nicht lösen dass wir in
unserem Arbeitsmarkt haben und dass sie
auch zu einem erheblichen Teil bis zum
heutigen Tag mit verantwortlich
ich will
abschließend einige Bemerkungen zur
Handelspolitik und zur
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit machen ja wir sind
auf Ihrer Seite wenn es darum geht die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der europäischen
Union zu verbessern nur wenn aus
Deutschland zu diesem Inflation
reduction Act der amerikanischen
Regierung Wochen und Monate
Sprachlosigkeit in der Europäischen
Union herrscht wenn sich der ständige
Vertreter der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
also der Botschafter bei der EU
öffentlich darüber beklagt dass er nicht
sprechfähig ist in den Gremien der
Europäischen Union weil es keine
gemeinsame Position der deutschen
Regierung gibt wenn er alleine ist mit
dem Vertreter aus Malta aus Zypern und
dann Deutschland diese drei Staaten
nicht sprechfähig sind in der
Europäischen Union wenn es um eine
Antwort auf diesen IRA geht dann ist die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit nicht durch
Brüsseler Politik beschädigt und in
Frage gestellt sondern die durch die
Uneinigkeit und die wochenlangen
Streitereien in ihrer Koalition der
Bundeskanzler insbesondere zwischen dem
Bundesfinanzminister und den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister
dann sprechen Sie dann sprechen Sie über
neue Freihandelsabkommen damit sind wir
auf ihrer Seite aber darf ich daran
erinnern zieht da hat sieben Jahre
sieben quälende Jahre gebraucht bis
grüne und Sozialdemokraten mal bereit
waren denen zuzustimmen sie waren in
Südamerika und verhandeln dort über
Merkur dieses Abkommen wird seit 15
Jahren verhandelt und ist bis jetzt am
Widerstand der Sozialdemokraten und der
Grünen im Deutschen Bundestag und im
Europäischen Parlament gescheiter das
lag nicht an uns das ist für diesen
Freihandelsabkommen nicht gekommen ist
und der Bundeskanzler über ttip und ein
mögliches feines Abkommen mit den
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika sprechen
sie schon gar nicht mehr ich weiß nicht
ob sie sich daran erinnern dieses
Abkommen war so gut wie aus verhandelt
und fertig es ist an dem Widerstand der
gesamten deutschen Linken und einiger
Gerät nicht Regierungsorganisationen
gescheitert weil sie mit einem
imaginären chlorhühnchenpolitik gemacht
haben gegen eine vernünftige
Handelspolitik gegenüber den Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika stellen sich mal
einen kurzen Augenblick vor stellen sich
mal ein kurzen Augenblick vor wir hätten
heute
wir hätten heute ja es ist interessant
zu beobachten dass sie genauso
dazwischen rufen wie die AFD da scheinen
sich in diesem Thema mit der AFD ja sehr
einig zu sein was die
behandelsbeziehungen zwischen Europa und
Amerika betrifft stellen sich mal einen
kurzen Augenblick vor wir hätten heute
ttip wir hätten dieses Abkommen wir
würden in Amerika genauso behandelt wie
die Kanadier und die Mexikaner hätten
wahrscheinlich freien Zugang zum
amerikanischen Markt und der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister müsste nicht
eine Bittsteller Reise nach Washington
machen sondern könnte sich auf einen
Abkommen Stützen mit dem wir eine
vernünftige Handelspolitik mit dem
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika hätten
also meine Schlussfolgerung daraus ist
ganz einfach
meine Schlussfolgerung daraus ist ganz
einfach ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg
und viel Glück bei den schwierigen und
wichtigen Verhandlungen in Brüssel
morgen und übermorgen aber die
wesentlichen Hausaufgaben in der
Asylpolitik in der Einwanderungspolitik
auch in der Wirtschaftspolitik und in
der Handelspolitik die müssen Sie hier
in Berlin machen und die werden umso
schwieriger jetzt zerstrittener diese
Regierung auch im Jahr 2023 bleibt
herzlichen Dank
für die Reaktion des CDU
csu-fraktionsschefs Friedrich Merz hier
der Oppositionsführer im Deutschen
Bundestag auf die Regierungserklärung
von Olaf Scholz sind auch auf die
Arbeit der Bundesregierung er hat unter
anderem von dem Bundeskanzler
vorgeworfen das große Teile
seiner Zeiten wenn sie sich nur auf dem
Papier finde beispielsweise das
Sondervermögen der Bundeswehr da gäbe
ist bislang noch keine Bestellung zum
Beispiel von Munition hören wir jetzt
für die Grünen deren
Fraktionsvorsitzende Katharina dröge
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen gestern während
unserer Fraktionssitzung hat mich die
SMS von einer guten Freundin erreicht
sie schrieb mir erleichtert die Familie
meines Cousins ist gerettet die Tochter
der Schwiegersohn und die drei kleinen
Enkelkindern waren unter den Trümmern
des fünfstöckigen Hauses verschüttet
worden indem sie lebten viele Stunden
bei eisiger Kälte hatte die Familie
ausgehalten bis sie gestern geborgen
werden konnte leider erreichte uns
einige Stunden später die traurige
Nachricht dass das kleinste Kind im
Krankenhaus gestorben ist es wurde vier
Jahre alt
es ist die Geschichte einer Familie in
dieser unfassbaren Katastrophe ich
erzähle sie weil die unvorstellbare Zahl
der jetzt schon mehr als 11.000 Toten
die das Erdbeben in Syrien in der Türkei
gekostet hat für viele Menschen und
unserem Land eben keine Zahl ist für
viele unserer FreundInnen und
KollegInnen sind es die Leben ihrer
Familienangehörigen und Freunde um die
Sie gerade bangen und trauern und ich
kann nur sagen wir hoffen und wir bangen
und wir trauern gemeinsam und wir
bemühen uns
und wir bemühen uns zu helfen wo wir
können und deswegen bin ich der
Bundesregierung bin ich der
Außenministerin und der Innenministerin
so dankbar dafür dass sie so schnell
gehandelt haben dass ihr wirklich jede
Hilfe angeboten habt die Deutschland an
dieser Stelle bieten konnte Zelte Decken
stromaggregatoren und Teams die bei der
Suche und der Bergung von vermissten
helfen danke an das THW danke an die
Malteser und die vielen vielen anderen
die jetzt gerade im Einsatz sind
es ist wichtig dass die Hilfe überall
ankommt auch in den entlegensten Dörfern
in der Türkei auch in Nordsyrien wo
bislang die einzige offene Grenzübergang
zerstört ist es müssen hier dringend
alle Grenzübergänge geöffnet werden
damit Hilfe ankommt und das ist jetzt
wirklich notwendig und zeitkritisch
Hilfe kommt aktuell aus vielen Länder
dieser Welt unter anderem auch aus der
Ukraine und das ist ein starkes Zeichen
der Solidarität eines Landes dass ich ja
gerade selbst in der Verteidigung gegen
den russischen Angriffskrieg befindet
ein Land das ja gerade selbst mit einer
humanitären Katastrophe fertig werden
muss weil Russland gezielt Wohnhäuser
angreift zivile Infrastruktur die Strom
und Wasserversorgung die Krankenhäuser
und Schulen und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir die Ukraine nicht nur
mit der Lieferung schwerer Waffen
unterstützen sondern auch mit
humanitärer Hilfe
sie Lieferung von Panzern ist wichtig
damit sich die Ukraine schützen und
verteidigen kann und deshalb bin ich so
erleichtert dass ich Deutschland
gemeinsam mit einigen anderen Ländern
dazu entschieden hat moderne Kampfpanzer
zu liefern das wird Leben retten
und an dieser Stelle
möchte ich aber auch auf sie eingehen
Herr Merz wenn man so empfindlich ist
wird Karnevals reden wenn es die eigene
Person betrifft dann sollte man seine
Worte gut wegen wenn man über andere
spricht und weil sie gerade auf die Rede
der Außenministerin eingegangen sind
möchte ich einen Kollegen von ihnen
zitieren der den Ton etwas besser
getroffen hat Herr Kiesewetter hat
geschrieben wir gemeinsam gehen gegen
den brutalen völkerrechtlichen
Angriffskrieg vor nichts anderes war die
Intention der Außenministerin in dieser
Versammlung und nicht anders ist sie zu
verstehen er hat allerdings auch
hinzugefügt wer etwas anderes
unterstellt der bedient russische
narrative und am Ende nützt dass der
russischen Desinformationskampagne
deswegen sollten Sie auf ihren Kollegen
hören und ihre eigenen Worte besser
bewegen
wir blicken jetzt auf den Europäischen
Rat der sich natürlich mit der Ukraine
beschäftigt aber auch mit einem anderen
Thema wo es um Hilfe und Unterstützung
geht und auch wenn die Debatten von
vielen und manchmal auch von Ihnen Herr
Merz am liebsten nur über Abschiebung
geführt werden sollte es bei der Frage
von Flucht und Migration in der
Europäischen Union primär erstmal um
Hilfe und Unterstützung gehen nicht um
die Finanzierung von Zeugen an den
EU-Außengrenzen wie einige leider
vorschlagen sondern um unsere gemeinsame
Verantwortung
Mensch flieht ohne Grund niemand
verlässt leichtfertig sein vertrautes
Umfeld das ist der Kern von Flucht und
Migration und deswegen ist es im Kern
auch unsere Aufgabe bei einer
gemeinsamen europäischen
Flüchtlingspolitik um bessere
Schutzstandard zu bringen um gemeinsame
Verantwortung bei der Aufnahme dieses
gut dass Deutschland erklärt hat dass
sie bereit sind im freiwilligen
Mechanismus auch voran zu gehen
und wenn man sich Menschen anguckt und
die Gründe warum sie fliehen neben Krieg
und Terror dann ist es oft auch Not und
deswegen müssen wir das Thema Bekämpfung
von Fluchtursachen genauso in den Blick
nehmen und hierzu gehören
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit und zivile
Krisenprävention das ist kein nice to
have das ist elementare Politik die wir
an dieser Stelle machen müssen und ich
würde mir wünschen in diesem Parlament
ist zu recht intensiv beruhen worden um
die Frage der Finanzierung von der
Bundeswehr von unseren
Verteidigungsausgaben diejenigen die das
so intensiv getan haben den wünsche ich
und ich wünsche uns allen dass wir mit
der gleichen Intensität aber auch darum
ringen würden wie wir eine entsprechende
Finanzierung der Entwicklung
Zusammenarbeit und der Normalität Hilfe
in diesem Haushalt Abbinden können eins
zu eins genauso wie es unser
Koalitionsvertrag auch vorsieht
und das zweite große Thema was auf dem
Europäischen Rat verhandelt wird das ist
der amerikanische Inflation redakt die
USA haben hier ein Zeichen gesetzt ein
Zeichen dass voll oft Klimaschutz setzt
und das ist gut so ein Stück weit ist es
aber auch eine Ansage gegenüber dem Rest
der Welt wer jetzt noch meint
klimaneutrale Technologien ausbremsen zu
müssen oder zu können der gefährdet am
Ende den Wirtschaftsstandort Europa
und das sage ich ganz klar in Richtung
derjenigen die in diesem Land immer
wieder aufs zögern aufs Zaudern und aus
Bremsen gesetzt haben eine vernünftige
Energieversorgung ist erneuerbar die
Industrie der Zukunft setzt auf grünen
Wasserstoff und der Antrieb von Autos
ist elektrisch so einfach ist das um
nichts anderes geht es hier gerade und
wer diese Politik nicht verinnerlicht
wer immer noch glaubt am alten
festhalten zu können da frage ich mich
wo wollen Sie wirtschaftspolitisch
eigentlich gerade hin wo wollen Sie
wirtschaftspolitisch eigentlich gerade
hin wo ist der Mut in der CDU geblieben
wo ist die Innovationskraft die sie
eigentlich immer so erzählen wie sie vor
sich hertragen wie glauben Sie ein
landwirtschaftspolitisch aufstellen zu
können wenn sie jeden Zukunftstrend
immer weiter blockieren und eine
Technologien der Vergangenheit
festhalten das ist am Ende keine
vernünftige wirtschaftspol itik das
schade dass nur dem Klima das schadet
auch der Wirtschaft in Europa
und Herr Merz uns ist aufgefallen Sie
haben den Namen der
kommissionspräsidentin ja noch nie in
einer ihrer reden erwähnt sie heißt
Ursula von der Leyen und gehört der CDU
an und die hat zum Glück eine sehr klare
Antwort auf diese Frage gefunden sie hat
ein Paket vorgeschlagen dass Europa grün
machen wird dass in Zukunft Technologien
investiert das mit dem fit vor 55 Paket
jetzt ein modernes Paket für Klimaschutz
in der Europäischen Union verantwortet
ich würde mir wünschen die Union wäre
stolz auf diese kommissionspräsidentin
statt einfach nur über diese Politik zu
schreiben
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
die Fraktionsvorsitzende der Grünen war
das hier und während ihrer Rede gab es
einen Wechsel
der Bundestagspräsident Wolfgang leitet
jetzt diese Sitzung ruft die nächste
Rednerin auf das wird sein alles beide
die Fraktionsvorsitzende der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
Präsident
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
Herr Scholz können Sie morgens
eigentlich noch ruhig in den Spiegel
schauen beim Gedanken an die geballte
Inkompetenz und cascade an Fehlleistung
für welche die von Ihnen geführte
Bundesregierung steht sie leisten sich
eine Außenministerin die in ihrem
Dilettantismus auf dem internationalen
Parkett mal eben eine Kriegserklärung an
Russland verkündet die im Rest der Welt
Hemer und Entsetzen auslöst homösam
wieder eingefangen werden muss eine
Außenministerin die sich nicht nur für
die ganze Welt zuständig führt sondern
auch für Länder die ich zitiere
hunderttausende Kilometer entfernt
liegen also irgendwo da draußen im
Sonnensystem
unglaublich
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck hausiert
derzeit weltweit in Sachen Klimaschutz
verkündet hochtragende Lieferabkommen
die gleich wieder zerplatzen und träumt
ganz offen davon Deutschland in einem
von Brüssel regierten eu-bundesstaat
aufgehen zu lassen
reden wir gar nicht erst sie sagen genau
es ist das was wir wollen reden wir gar
nicht erst von ihrer demnächst nur noch
Teilzeit Innenministerin die ihr Amt den
nächsten Dreivierteljahr als
wahlkampfplattform und Sicherheitsgurt
für ihre Karrierepläne zu missbrauchen
gedenkt ihre eigentliche Aufgabe die
Sicherheit der Bürger hat sie über ihre
Besessenheit im Kampf gegen Rechts und
bei der Öffnung der letzten
migrationschleusen dieses unsäglichen
einbürgerungsgesetzes ja schon länger
sträflich vernachlässigt
oder ihr längst zur
tragischen
Minister lauter
Bach und nicht nur noch damit
beschäftigt ist anderen die Schuld für
seine Corona blindflüge und sein
Versagen in allen anderen Aufgaben
zuzuschieben solch ein kbnet kann
niemand ernst nehmen unter ihrer
Regierung wird Deutschland vollends zum
gespürt der Welt und wird in den Augen
neutraler Beobachter einen
Entwicklungsland immer ähnlicher und in
dieser Hinsicht sind sie tatsächlich der
würdige Nachfolger von Angela Merkel
die außenpolitischen Schuhe früherer
Bundeskanzler denken an Konrad Adenauer
oder eines Helmut Schmidt sind ihnen zu
groß
ein ums andere Mal lassen Sie sich in
Fragen die für die Zukunft unseres
Landes von entscheidender Bedeutung sind
wie ein Schuljunge vorführen sie standen
Stunden daneben als der Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten vor der Weltpresse
auftrumpfte die USA hätten die Mittel um
die im Betriebnahme der
ostsee-erdgasleitung nordstream 2 zu
verhindern mehr als ein halbes Jahr nach
der Sprengung der beiden Leitung
schweigen sie immer noch zu den
Verantwortlichen für diesen
offenkundigstaats terroristischen Akt
der Jubel der us
viel zu Außenministerin Victoria newland
darüber dass eine für die
Energieversorgung Deutschlands vitale
Infrastruktur nur noch ich zitiere ein
Stück Metall auf dem Meeresgrund sei
Marc vielleicht eine Antwort sein aber
die Bürger dieses Landes erwarten von
Ihnen Aufklärung wer diesen Anschlag auf
eine Lebensader der deutschen Industrie
verübt hat und sie wollen von Ihnen
hören was sie konkret unternehmen um die
Belieferung Deutschlands mit günstigen
und verfügbaren Energieträgern auch aus
Russland wieder zu ermöglichen
Flüssiggas aus den USA zu überteuerten
Kosten ist keine Lösung die
explodierenden Preise für Energieimporte
sind zusammen mit der EZB ausgelösten
hohen Inflation der Grund die Ursache
für den Kaufkraftverlust real,-
to Löhne der Bundesbürger und zwar von
vier Prozent im letzten Jahr ein solcher
Wohlstandsverlust ist beispiellos in der
Geschichte Deutschlands
beispiellos
er treibt die Mittelschicht in die
Verarmung und das produktive Gewerbe aus
dem Land und in die Arme der
amerikanischen Anwerber die mit
niedrigen Steuern und niedrigen
Energiekosten dafür werben bei
gleichzeitigem Protektionismus der
eigenen
amerikanischen Industrie das muss man
sich mal vorstellen und sie leisten
dieser die Industrialisierung auch noch
Vorschub die Windräder mit denen ihre
Regierung dieses Land noch weiter voll
stellen will sind ebenfalls keine Lösung
sie sind subventionsgräber und
geldvernichtungsmaschinen die unsere
Energieproblem noch verschärfen werden
wenn kein Wind weht liefern 50 oder 100
Windräder genauso wenig Strom wie die
derzeitigen 30.000 die unsere Landschaft
bereits verhandeln die sogenannten
erneuerbaren Energiequellen tragen
derzeit weniger zur Stromversorgung
Deutschlands bei als die letzten drei
verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke sie
abzuschalten wäre ökonomischer Suizid da
lassen Sie von der SPD das können wir
uns vorstellen
da können Sie noch so auf den Bürgern
und der Wirtschaft in den Rücken fallen
und die abschaltdebatte für beendet
erklären deutschland braucht den
Wiedereinstieg in die Kernkraft ja
natürlich brauchen wir das
fragen Sie morgen in Brüssel die anderen
Regierungschef Chefs Herr Bundeskanzler
niemand findet den Deutschen
anti-kernkraft waren gut niemand will
Ihnen auf diesem Weg folgen und jetzt
bekommen sie auch noch von den
europäischen Partnern Druck aufgrund
ihrer unverantwortlichen Asyl und
Einbürgerungspolitik wir freuen uns auf
dem Gipfel gehen Sie voran herr Scholz
wie sie das ja immer tun genauso wie bei
der Lieferung bei der fatalen
Entscheidung der Kampfpanzer in die
Ukraine der anfängliches zögern ehrt sie
am Ende haben sie sich aber doch von den
Kriegstreibern in ihren eigenen Reihen
und jenseits des Atlantiks dazu nötigen
lassen diesen Schritt zu gehen und
Deutschland das will ich immer was sagen
und Deutschland de factor zur
Kriegspartei zu machen in einem Krieg
der nicht der unsere ist
darum geht es doch und siehe da
und siehe da die Partner ihre tollen
Partner haben es gar nicht mehr so eilig
mit den eigenen Panzern die haben es gar
nicht mehr so eilig die USA wollen ihre
Panzer erst in einem Jahr liefern auch
noch abgespeckt sie aber haben dem neuen
Verteidigungsminister den sie als
letztes Aufgebot irgendwie mobilisiert
haben als einen der ersten Termine nach
Amtsantritt zugemutet einer der wenigen
funktionierenden panzerkompanien der
Bundeswehr zu erklären dass sie ihre
modernen und einsatzbereiten Kampfpanzer
abgeben müssen
und das ist moderne und einsatzbereite
Kampfpanzer überhaupt noch in der
Bundeswehr geht nach 16 Jahren Merkel
ist ja sowieso schon verwunderlich das
muss man ja mal sagen also auch hier
mehr März immer hier alles da drauf zu
schieben sie waren ja 16 Jahre in der
Regierung da und sie haben das alles in
Grund und Boden gewirtschaftet und wenn
sie über das Sondervermögen sprechen der
Bundeswehr das Sondervermögen was hier
durchgegangen ist das war dazu bestimmt
die Bundeswehr zu ertüchtigen und nicht
irgendwelche Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine
zu verschenken so wie wir das gerade
machen
sie nehmen die Bundeswehr aus und
unterminieren unsere
Verteidigungsfähigkeit um den Krieg in
der Ukraine zu verlängern und
Deutschland zu Zielscheibe zur
Zielscheibe zu machen sie machen
Deutschland zur Zielscheibe während die
us-rüstungsindustrie in sicherer erfährt
Entfernung in sicherer Entfernung sehr
gute Geschäfte macht die Begeisterung
für Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine und
für Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland
die Deutschland und Europa wohlgemerken
mehr Schaden als Moskau bleibt auf die
USA und ihre europäische Gefolgschaft
beschränkt im Rest der Welt verfolgt man
eigene Interessen das hat ihn zuletzt
ihr Sozialisten Genosse Lula vor Augen
geführt als er sie auf ihrer Brasilien
Reise ein weiteres Mal vor aller Welt
vorführte Brasilien hat kein Interesse
an einer Klimapolitik nach deutschen
Vorstellung die geradewegs in die
Industrialisierung und Wohlstandsverlust
führt
Brasilien hat auch kein Interesse an
grünem Ideologie Spielzeug wie den
weltfremden Bürokratiemonster
lieferkettengesetz das den Freihandel
behindert brasilien will nicht durch
Waffenlieferung zur Kriegspartei werden
sondern sein Gewicht in die Waagschale
werfen genau wie Indien und China auch
ein Friedensabkommen für die Ukraine zu
vermitteln
eine solche Initiative
hätte von ihnen der Bundeskanzler kommen
können und sie hätte längst von
Deutschland kommen müssen
fragen Sie einmal nicht die ungedienten
sofa-strategen aus den
Koalitionsfraktionen und der Union
fragen Sie erfahrene Militärs weder die
Ukraine nach Russland werden in diesem
Krieg ihre Maximalziele erreichen können
um ihnen zu beenden werden sie früher
oder später einen Kompromiss aushandeln
müssen die Frage ist wie viele Menschen
bis dahin noch sterben müssen wie viel
Zerstörung und Leid bis dahin noch
angerichtet wird aber sie können eine
atomacht nicht in die totale Niederlage
zwingen ohne zu riskieren die Welt in
die Luft zu jagen die von ihnen
belächelte Sorge vor einer Eskalation
des Krieges zum Atomkrieg die viele
Bürger umtreibt ist nicht irrational sie
ist real und der große
SPD-Politiker ich komme zum Ende der
Präsident was auch Otto von Bismarck
schon wusste den ihr Koalition Partner
bekanntlich canceln will
Staaten haben keine Freunde sondern
Staaten haben Interessen
vertreten Sie also die Interessen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland Herr
Bundeskanzler ich wünsche Ihnen dabei
viel Erfolg vielen Dank
alles beide war das für die afd-fraktion
ja wenig eigentlich zu den eigentlichen
Themen des EU-Gipfels in ihrer Rede aber
es war so was wir alle Generalabrechnung
mit dem heimkabinett jetzt wird der
Bundestagsvizepräsident Wolfgang Kubicki
hier in der Aussprache zu der
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
und zum Sondergipfel der EU der Morgen
in Brüssel startet in den nächsten
Redner aufrufen kommt aus den rein der
Liberalen das ist Johannes Vogel der
Parlamentarische Geschäftsführer
[Applaus]
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nach dieser Rede der fünften
Kolonne Moskau aus und weil wir die
letzte Sitzungswoche haben bevor sich
der völkerrechtswidrige Überfall Putins
und der Beginn der russischen
Kriegsverbrechen am tapferen
ukrainischen Volk das erste Jahr Jens
erste Mal jähren will ich noch mal klar
sagen es ist der einzige Weg
dass wir zufrieden kommen ist dass die
Ukraine den Kampf um die Territorium
gewinnen und deshalb bin ich der
Bundesregierung im Namen meiner Fraktion
und auch vor dem Europäischen Rat sehr
dankbar dass wir die Ukraine noch
stärker unterstützen und danke auch dem
Verteidigungsminister für den
kurzfristigen Besuch in den letzten
Tagen in Kiew denn dass wir jetzt auch
mit mehr Kampf und Schützenpanzer dafür
sorgen dass die Ukraine für die kommende
Frühjahrsoffensive gut ausgerichtet ist
dass es erstens unsere ausgerüstet ist
erstens unsere moralische Verantwortung
und zweitens umso schneller die Ukraine
gewinnt und so schneller wird es Frieden
geben vielen Dank dafür
ich will aber aus tagesaktuellen Anlass
ganz kurz Frau sehr verehrte liebe Frau
Wehrbeauftragte auch sagen eine Debatte
die wir nach unserer Überzeugung nicht
führen sollten ist die über die
Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht das
sage ich auch klar das wird mit den
Freien Demokraten nicht geben denn wir
sollten nicht darüber diskutieren wie
viel Zwang wir brauchen wir brauchen gar
keinen Zwang es wäre erstens eine
Frechheit gegenüber der jungen
Generation und ihrem exorbitanten
Beitrag auch in der corona-krise und vor
allem würde es uns aufhalten auf dem Weg
zur Profi Bundeswehr gut ausgestattet
die wir brauchen und ich will klar sagen
ja wir haben ein Problem mit
Nachwuchsgewinnung bei der Bundeswehr
aber was wir dafür tun können das
anzugehen ist dass wir den Soldaten und
Soldaten den Respekt verschaffen den sie
verdienen solange wir über
Jugendoffiziere in Schulen politische
diskutieren und solange Soldatin
Soldaten in diesem Land in Uniform zum
Beispiel ange feindet werden das ist das
Problem dass wir angehen müssen und dann
klappt auch mit der Nachwuchsgewinnung
bei der Bundeswehr meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
heutigen Tag müssen wir uns aber
natürlich auch um die angemessene
europäische Reaktion auf den Inflation
reduction Act unterhalten das ist
richtig und sehr geehrter Herr
Bundeskanzler ich bin sehr dankbar für
die klare Aussage erstens das klare
aufzählen wie viel Mittel wir in Europa
bereits einsetzen also sind offenbar ja
ein Mangel an Mittel nicht das Problem
und die klare Aussage dass ein
Subventionswettlauf nicht die Antwort
sein darf das ist absolut richtig und ja
lieber verehrter Herr Merz es ist
richtig dass wir natürlich gar nicht
erst da müssen wir auch Klartext reden
in dieser schwierigen Lage wären wenn
wir schon ein Freihandelsabkommen mit
den USA hätten das ist richtig Kanada
und andere sind ausgenommen nur lieber
Herr Merz so von Freihändler zu
Freihändler sie haben es ja in
jahrelanger Regierungsbeteiligung nicht
mal geschafft dass der Deutsche
Bundestag ceta ratifiziert wir haben
jetzt ceta-ratifiziert in dieser
Koalition oder Beteiligung der Freien
Demokraten und uns dazu bekannt schwarz
auf weiß per Beschluss des Deutschen
Bundestages und uns dazu bekannt dass
wir bei den anderen Freihandelsabkommen
Chile Mexiko mercusor vorankommen wollen
und sogar bekannt Schwarz auf Weiß zu
einem Neuanlauf für ein
freiheitsabkommen mit den USA was war
denn da die Bilanz der Union meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das kann sich
ja eindeutig sehen lassen
richtig ist aber auch dass das natürlich
nicht kurzfristig gelingen wird und
deshalb muss Europa gemeinsam mit Japan
und Südkorea jetzt daran arbeiten dass
bereits das Bekenntnis zum
transatlantischen Freihandel das bereits
die Abkommen die wir haben uns
Zwischenschritte dahin dafür sorgen dass
der Inflation redakt nicht zur
transatlantischen Hürde wird darüber
hinaus sollten wir uns Gedanken machen
was wir eigentlich tun können um hier zu
Lande Innovationskraft und
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit durch gute
Rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern das muss
doch die politische Aufgabe sein und
dazu gehört natürlich dass wir den
Arbeitskräfte und Fachkräftemangel
angegeben und lieber Herr märz an der
Stelle noch ein Wort zu dem was sie eben
zu Migration gesagt haben die Union war
ja eben in der Rede sehr gut bei der
Problemanalyse europäische Asylsystem
muss reformiert werden aber was ist denn
da die Bilanz der letzten Jahrzehnte
gewesen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der Union und eins will ich auch
ganz klar sagen ich weiß dass sie das
immer nicht mehr hören können weil so
weh tut aber eins will ich auch ganz
klar sagen ja wir müssen besser werden
bei der Ordnung der Migration die
irreguläre Migration muss runter und
deshalb muss zum Beispiel auch die
rückführungsoffensive aus unserem
Koalitionsvertrag jetzt schnell mit
leeren gefüllt werden durch diese
Bundesregierung das ist richtig aber das
auszuspielen lieber Herr Merz gegen
Migration auf den Arbeitsmarkt das haben
sie eben gemacht wir könnten jetzt
insgesamt nicht mehr Einwanderung
vertragen das ist genau der falsche Weg
den reguläre Migration muss hoch denn
ein Einwanderungsland ist es was uns
stark macht und der Fachkräftemangel ist
ein zu einer der größten wachstumshürden
geworden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das müssen wir ändern
ich will aber auch einen letzten
Gedanken zum Thema
was macht uns als Standort stark und was
ist auch die richtige Antwort in der
Wettbewerbspolitik sagen
Einwanderungsland Offenheit für neue
Technologien Marktwirtschaft und
Unternehmertum das hat uns zum Beispiel
in der corona-krise den Impfstoff
gebracht dass wir gerade aber gehört
haben dass ein zukunftsunternehmen wie
biontech Teile seiner Krebsforschung
nach Großbritannien verlagert das muss
uns in der Tat wach rütteln wir müssen
besser werden bei Rahmenbedingungen für
Unternehmertum bei Offenheit für neue
Technologien und brauchen weniger
preisigkeit und Bürokratie das ist
richtig und deshalb müssen wir auch
schneller werden bei allen Projekten die
wir in diesem Land so angehen liebe
Kollegen lieber herr Präsident das ist
ein Projekt so angehen liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen von den Grünen ein
Tempolimit für Infrastrukturprojekte
können wir uns in keinem Bereich leisten
sondern wir müssen bei
schienenstromstraßen windkrädern an eben
auch bei Straßen und Neubau von
Autobahnen schneller werden wir gehen
diese Woche einen ersten Schritt aber
weitere müssen folgen denn so legen wir
den Hebel um für mehr Tempo und Wachstum
diesem Land und das ist notwendig vielen
Dank ja das konnte sich Johannes Vogel
nicht verkneifen gegenüber dem grünen
Koalitionspartner da noch einen kleinen
Haken zu schlagen aber schlagen wir
nochmal den Bogen zum Anfang seiner Rede
da hat er die wir beauftragte die sie
auch sehen hier die an der Debatte time
und Eva Högl angesprochen und hat ganz
klar gesagt mit den Freien Demokraten
wird es keine Wiedereinführung der
Wehrpflicht geben den genau das hat
gefordert zumindest eine Diskussion
darüber über eine mögliche Einführung
einer neuen Art von Wehrpflicht
am regnerpult jetzt die nächste Rednerin
Mira Mohammed Ali die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der Linken
das richtiges Beileid all den Familien
und Freunden der Opfer der schrecklichen
Erdbeben sind in der Türkei in Syrien
aussprechen ich danke von Herzen allen
die jetzt helfen in der Tat wir müssen
alle gemeinsam alles Menschenmögliche
tun um allen Betroffenen möglichst
schnell helfen zu können
seit fast einem Jahr Frucht in der
Ukraine Putin schrecklicher
Angriffskrieg es musste das oberste Ziel
sein dass dieser Krieg möglichst schnell
endet die Waffen müssen endlich
schweigen
stattdessen werden sie euch heute im
Europäischen Rat aber wieder über
Sanktionen und Waffenlieferungen beraten
mittlerweile sind sie beim zehnten
Sanktionspaket angelangt bei den ersten
wurde angekündigt dass das Russland
wirtschaftlich ruinieren würde das aber
nicht passiert sie haben auch behauptet
die Sanktionen werden russlandsfähigkeit
Krieg zu führen erheblich
beeinträchtigen auch das ist nicht
passiert fakt ist allerdings ihre
Sanktionspolitik hat verheerende
Auswirkungen auf die wirtschaftliche
Stabilität in Deutschland in Europa und
in den Ländern des globalens laut einer
aktuellen Umfrage der
Verbraucherzentrale muss den letzten
drei Monaten musste jeder 7 Mensch in
Deutschland sein Konto ins Minus ziehen
um über den Monat zu kommen Millionen
Menschen leben sogar dauerhaft in den
Miesen Gründe sind die Inflation
insbesondere die gestiegenen
Energiepreise in einer Umfrage der
Schufa gaben drei von vier Befragten an
bei Lebensmitteln jetzt sparen zu müssen
und wissen Sie was das für ärmere
Familien bedeutet das Scholz die Eltern
sparen am eigenen essen um ihre Kinder
überhaupt noch etwas zu Essen auf den
Tisch bringen zu können armutsrentner
verzweifeln darum hören Sie endlich auch
die Lage zu beschönigen das haben sie
heute auch wieder getan öffnen sie die
Augen behandeln sie es ist dringend Zeit
dafür
und während Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck
sich dafür feiern lässt für die vollen
Gasspeicher und neue lng-terminals
fallindustriebetriebe teilweise einfach
weiter hinten unter besonders in
Ostdeutschland zum Beispiel die wichtige
Raffinerie PCK Suite der Brandenburger
Ministerpräsident hat jetzt sogar zum
Krisengipfel eingeladen weil all ihre
schönen Versprechungen du nicht gehalten
werden Herr habing und das geht so nicht
außerdem steht fest dass durch ihre
Energiepolitik in Ländern des globalen
Südens erhebliche Versorgungslücken
entstehen denn Deutschland kauft das Gas
zu jedem noch so hohen Preis auf dem
Weltmarkt für die betroffenen Länder
heißt das Stromausfälle steigende Armut
Störung der Wasserversorgung das
gefährdet Menschenleben das ist einfach
unverantwortlich muss es so sagen und
außerdem müssen diese Länder jetzt
wieder stärker auf Öl Erdöl und Kohle
zurückgreifen das ist schlecht fürs
Klima
aber auch das scheint nicht mehr zu
stören auch nicht die Grünen schließlich
gilt es einen Krieg zu gewinnen sagt
auch Werbung
Karneval Scherze macht über Leoparden
ich muss sagen das ist ihre Position als
Beschäftigung unseres Landes einfach
unwürdig
insgesamt finde ich
dass dieser von Teilen der Grünen der
FDP geführte Wettkampf um den besten
leopardenwitz absolut unverantwortlich
ist was für eine entsetzliche
Verniedlichung des Krieges und genauso
übrigens das Ringen um das Beste selfie
aus dem Kriegsgebiet ein Krieg darf
keine Bühne für Selbstdarsteller sein
meine Damen und Herren
entgegen
entgegen jeder Vernunft halten Sie aber
daran fest dass Russland im militärische
Mitteln besiegt werden soll Herr
Pistorius verkündet stolz 178
Kampfpanzer sollen geliefert werden wo
soll das enden viele Experten zum
Beispiel die RAND Corporation aus den
USA kommt zum Ergebnis dass der Krieg
militärisch nicht zu gewinnen ist das
ein konservativer things sind das ist
auch Putin verstehe
sie riskieren immer mehr dass
Deutschland zur Kriegspartei wird die
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung fürchtet das
und ich muss Ihnen was sagen die Leute
haben leider recht was wir brauchen ist
eine diplomatische Offensive wie sie zum
Beispiel Präsident Lola aus Brasilien
fordert er weigert sich auch
in Munition für die Panzer zu verkaufen
und fordert sich stattdessen auf herr
Scholz Ihnen dabei zu unterstützen ein
Format für Friedensverhandlungen
aufzubauen das ist der richtige Weg und
Lola der vor kurzem noch zu Recht für
seinen Sieg gegen den Faschisten wollte
zu naro gefeiert wurde der wird
hierzulande für diesen Ruf nach
Diplomatie teilweise als Frieden
schwurbler diffamiert ich finde das
zeigt ziemlich deutlich wie absurd diese
Debatte geworden ist das wirklich
hochgefährlich
wissen Sie wir wissen dass Diplomatie
auch in diesem Krieg wirken kann denken
wir an das getreideabkommen denken wir
an den laufenden Gefangenen Austausch
der ehemalige israelische Premier
Natalie Bennet der sagte sogar dass ein
Waffenstillstand bereits im letzten Jahr
fast fertig ausgehandelt war nur die USA
und die britische Regierung sein damals
dagegen gewesen warum wohl Herrschaft
darum korrigieren Sie Ihren Kurs wir
brauchen endlich ernsthaft für den
Frieden danke schön
[Applaus]
ich habe sie doch gar nicht unterbrochen
macht doch immer nur deutlich dass die
Uhr abgelaufen also die Zeit abgelaufen
ist
schauen wir uns also es ist sozusagen
eine Aufforderung zum Ende der Rede zu
kommen
ich wollte sie nicht unterbrechen in
ihrem
schreiben nächster Redner ist der
Kollege Axel Schäfer SPD-Fraktion
herr Präsident liebe Kollegin
meine Partnerstadt von Bochum ist jetzt
und ich habe den Bundestag bei der Wahl
während der Orangenen Revolution in der
Ukraine vertreten
deshalb möchte ich hier mit einem Zitat
mit Ihrer Erlaubnis herr Präsident
beginnen
ich möchte den Bundeskanzler danken für
seinen Lieder Chip und sein standhaftes
Engagement in unseren gemeinsamen
Anstrengung zu Unterstützung der Ukraine
Deutschland hatte richtig aufgestockt
der Kanzler ist eine starke Stimme für
einheitliche und enge Freundschaft Joe
Biden Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten
genauso ist es liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und es gibt ein zweites was genauso
wichtig ist wir haben in diesem Jahr das
schrecklichen Krieges den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
hinbekommen
gesellschaftlicher Zusammenhalt heißt
dass in einer Bevölkerung wo es manchmal
fifty fifty ist ob man Waffen liefert
oder nicht und wo wir erstmals vor diese
Frage gestellt worden sind und gehandelt
haben das ist dann gelungen ist dass
eben nicht Hunderttausende auf die
Straße gegangen sind und Kriegstreiberei
oder so geschrien haben sondern das ist
da jetzt eine mehrheitliche Zustimmung
gibt für die Politik dieses
Bundeskanzlers und das ist auch gut so
aber ich weiß dass es auch Kritik gibt
und deshalb ein anderes Zitat wieder mit
Genehmigung des Präsidenten
Kanzler Scholz gefährdet den Frieden
auch für unser Land
seine Feigheit vor Ideologen und zünigen
wie Mütze nicht in der SPD hat bereits
vielen tausend Menschen das Leben
gekostet und droht den Krieg nach
Deutschland zu bringen Michael Brandt
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
Fuldaer Zeitung am 25 Februar das war
derselbe Tag wie Joe beiden dieser
Erklärung abgegeben hat und das ist
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
CDU wo kein Widerspruch öffentlich kam
genau das ist völlig unakzeptabel hier
in diesem Haus
aber es war ein Bundeskanzler gibt es ja
in schwierigen Situationen manchmal ein
geschichtlichen Trost ich bin sehr lange
dabei ich weiß als Willy Brandt
beschimpft worden ist wegen seiner
Entspannungspolitik aus der Union auch
mit Worten wie Verräter ich erinnere
mich an Wahlkämpfe in den 80er Jahren
gegen Helmut Schmidt Freiheit und ohne
stadtsozialismus und ich weiß auch noch
sehr genau wie unsere Ablehnung des
Irakkrieges durch Kanzler Gerhard
Schröder in Amerika interniert wurde
dieser Kanzler spricht nicht für
Deutschland
in all diesen Fällen weil Willy
brandtspolitik bei Helmut Schmidt auch
bei Schröder zum Irakkrieg und jetzt bei
Olaf Scholz hat die Union sich geehrt
und das muss man vor der Geschichte und
auch aktuell sagen die Union lag falsch
und die Union wird wieder falsch liegen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und es ist es ist ein ganz anderes
europäisches Problem was ansteht und was
hier ja konsequent konsequent
verschwiegen wird nämlich die teilweise
Ausgrenzung ihre
parteifamilien nach rechts und
Rechtsaußen Manfred Weber Vorsitzender
der
evp-mitglied versucht gerade die
postfaschistische Partei Italiens von
Frau Meloni einfach so
christdemokratisch zu vereinnahmen und
ich finde ich finde nachdem wir in
Schweden schon Regierungen haben wo es
eine Entgrenzung nach rechts gegeben hat
wo wir eine Entgrenzung auch nach rechts
in Italien erlebt haben wo bereits eine
christdemokratische Partei nach
Rechtsaußen gewandert ist wie die
fidisch kann das hier im Deutschen
Bundestag nicht unwidersprochen
eingenommen werden das ist eine Politik
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union wo wir auch mal Widerspruch
erwarten und keine Gemeinsamkeit mit
solchen politischen Kräften
[Applaus]
und
und Liebe und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das was auch morgen wieder
ansteht nämlich der Punkt die
Erweiterung die Vertiefung der
Europäischen Union und es war gut und
richtig dass auch von diesem
Bundeskanzler neue Initiativen gekommen
sind sowohl was den Westbalkan anbelangt
als auch vor allem Ukraine und Nord
Mazedonien aber ich sage Ihnen auch ganz
persönlich
die Kopenhagener Kriterien gelten aber
es wird nicht das Ende der Geschichte
sein wir werden auch für den Westbalkan
und wir werden auch für die Ukraine eine
Beschleunigung brauchen als wird nicht
mehr so lange dauern können wie bisher
ich weiß welche außergewöhnlichen
Anstrengungen das erfordert auch in der
Veränderung dieses kriegsgeplagten
Landes intern aber es wird so kommen
müssen und das ist auch richtig so in
diesem gemeinsamen Europa für unsere
Arbeit für den Frieden und dafür stehen
wir hier vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Schäfer
als nächster Redner hält das Wort der
Kollege Alexander Dobrindt
cdu/csu-fraktion und Alexander
herr Präsident sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Bundeskanzler sehr wohl
Zusammenschluss ihrer Rede mitgeteilt
führen heißt für sie zusammenführen
Lösungen gemeinsame Arbeiten die
Realität in Europa schaut aber doch so
aus dass zunehmend die Länder ohne
Deutschland gemeinsame Linie finden das
ist das was passiert
Frankreich und Spanien beispielsweise
planen als Antwort auf den
amerikanischen reduction Act einen neuen
schulden-club in Brüssel eine neue
Schulden Vergemeinschaftung das ist
ihnen mitgeteilt der Bundeskanzler ich
hätte erwartet dass sie uns heute eine
klare Botschaft liefern wie sie dazu
stehen wollen Sie diesen schuldenklub
beitreten werden Sie diesen Versuchen
widerstehen unsere Erwartung ist an der
Stelle ganz klar schließen sie sich
nicht einem Schulden packt an in Brüssel
sondern führen Sie eine
stabilitätsabhackt an in Europa
sie haben uns heute in ihrer Rede bei
der dem Thema Verteidigung ihre Erfolge
der Vergangenheit
mitgeteilt sich ihre Erfolge gerühmt
sehr geehrter der Bundeskanzler seit
ihrer Zeiten Wende vom letzten Jahr
unterstütze ich in diesem Bereich was
sie sagen ich bin nur enttäuscht
enttäuscht von dem was sie machen ich
unterstütze das 2% Ziel ich bin
enttäuscht dass sie es nicht einlösen
ich unterstütze die 100 Milliarden ich
bin enttäuscht dass sie sie nicht
ausgeben sie waren letzte Woche in
Brasilien sie haben nicht nur um
Klimaschutz sondern vor allem auch um
Munition gebeten Herr Bundeskanzler ich
sage Ihnen hören sie auf um Munition zu
bitten fangen sie an Munition zu
bestellen das ist der sinnvolle Weg
sie haben heute beim Thema Migration
davon gesprochen dass sie Solidarität
gegenüber den Mitgliedsstaaten an der
EU-Außengrenze walten lassen wollen ja
die Solidarität allerdings die unsere
Partnerländer in Deutschland einfordern
die ist dass sie aufhören in Deutschland
Anreize für illegale Zuwanderung zu
erhöhen sie vermischen Asyl mit
fachkräftezuwanderung sie vermischen
Asyl mit staatsbürgerschaftrecht und sie
machen aus Ausreisepflicht ein
Aufenthaltsrecht acht Länder haben sich
in dieser Woche bereits
zusammengeschlossen und wollen die
schnellstmögliche Begrenzung der irrige
irregulären Zuwanderung in Europa
erreichen Herr Bundeskanzler zeigen sie
Solidarität unterstützen Sie diese
Initiative und geben sie morgen in
Brüssel die klare Zusage keine weiteren
Anreize für ihre Migration in
Deutschland zu schaffen
und sehr geehrte Frau Kollegin dröge sie
haben in ihrer Rede davon gesprochen
dass die Maßnahmen die in Europa zur
Zeit diskutiert werden zur Begrenzung
der irregulären Migration der Sie diese
nicht teilen nicht unterstützen und auch
nicht umsetzen wollen so war das
zumindest zu verstehen ich will Ihnen
hier ein Zitat aus einem aktuellen
Interview mitgeben das heißt wörtlich
zitiert wir müssen die Zuwanderung
begrenzen wir haben unsere
Leistungsgrenzen erreicht wir können das
nicht mehr verantworten das sind keine
Worte von Alexander Dobrindt das sind
die Worte von Jens Markus Scherf dem
grünen Landrat von Miltenberg nehmen Sie
die Stimmen aus ihrer eigenen Partei war
und leisten sie einen Beitrag dass wir
die Migration die reguläre Migration
nach Europa begrenzen herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank
Alexander Dobrindt war das der
landesgruppenchef der CSU ja die
Migrationspolitik ist eine der ganz
großen Baustellen in der Europäischen
Union es wird normal Thema jetzt auf
diesen Sondergipfel sein ob man wirklich
zusammenkommt da muss man mal auf die
nächsten beiden Tage dann schauen Anton
Hofreiter jetzt für die Grünen
Vorsitzender des europaausschusses
Ort bei einer ganze Reihe zentraler
Themen besprochen es geht um die weitere
Unterstützung der Ukraine es geht darum
wie wir klug auf den Inflation reduction
Antworten und wie wir wenigstens zu
Ansätzen einer gemeinsamen
Migrationspolitik kommen und ja in allen
Bereichen ist in Deutschland einiges zu
tun und es ist absolut gut und richtig
dass wir knapp ein Jahr nach
Kriegsbeginn und jetzt entschieden haben
auch Kampfpanzer in die Ukraine zu
liefern deshalb ist es jetzt umso
wichtiger nach dieser Zeit dass wir so
schnell wie möglich mit der Ausbildung
beginnen und so schnell wie möglich
dafür sorgen dass ausreichende
Ersatzteile für dieses Material gibt
denn die russische Frühlingsoffensive
steht kurz bevor und deshalb besser
jetzt schnell handeln als zu lange
warten
dann wissen Sie liebe Vertreterinnen und
Vertreter von der Union
sie tun ja gerne so als wenn sie
besonders fleißig auf Seiten der Ukraine
stehen würden aber das ganze wird halt
dann unglaubwürdig wenn man aus einem
Versprecher der Außenministerin hier
ganz bewusst russische narrative
aufnimmt und deshalb nicht die Ukraine
unterstützt sondern russische
kriegspopaganda hier unterstützt das ist
einfach ein riesen Problem Herr märz und
damit schaden sie den Zusammenhalt bei
uns im Land und schaden sie der
europäische Solidarität im Kampf gegen
den russischen Angriffskrieg
und
was die Frage des Umgangs mit der
Migration überhaupt nicht trivial ist da
glaube ich sind wir uns einig und ich
hoffe wir sind uns auch einig dass wir
endlich dafür sorgen dass eine der
tödlichsten Grenzen der Welt nämlich die
Südgrenze der Europäischen Union weniger
tödlich wird aber wissen Sie wenn Sie so
über Migration sprechen wie sie hier
sprechen tragen sie nicht zur Lösung der
Probleme bei sondern treiben nur
insbesondere Wähler der Union von der
Union Weg zur AFD das ist das einzige
was sie mit dieser Art von sprechen
erreichten und es nutzt überhaupt
niemand nicht wir sollten uns als
Demokraten einig sein dass wir alles
dafür tun wollen dass die
Rechtsradikalen zukünftig nicht mehr in
den Parlamenten vertreten sind
und beim Inflation reduction Act ich
glaube das ist schon angesprochen worden
ist der erste Punkt wir sollten uns
einfach richtig drüber freuen dass die
USA jetzt endlich was für Klimaschutz
tut nämlich die Klimakrise als Mittel-
und langfristigst gefährlichste Krise
für uns Menschen auf diesem Planeten
kriegen wir nur in Griff doch intensive
internationale Kooperation und das alle
Länder auf der Welt was dagegen tun und
es ist erstmal ein guter Schritt dass
die USA da jetzt richtig viel tun wollen
und deshalb und deshalb kommt jetzt
darauf an dass wir ein Wettbewerb
entfachen wer tut am meisten sozusagen
wer baut am schnellsten erneuerbare
Energien aus wer schafft am schnellsten
belastbare wasserstoffnetze wer sagt am
schnellsten dafür dass die Mobilität
emissionsfrei wird wer sagt am
schnellsten dafür dass moderne
Chemieindustrie ohne fossile Rohstoffe
auskommt das ist die Aufgabe die wir
haben und da kommt es halt auch darauf
an dass wir aus Deutschland keine
Germany first Politik machen und deshalb
nicht nur Subventionen erleichtern
sondern auch dafür sorgen dass Länder
die weniger Geld zur Verfügung haben
innerhalb der Europäischen Union
investieren können nicht eine der besten
Errungenschaften Europäischen Union ist
der Binnenmarkt und die Antwort auf
einen Flächen redakt muss so ausschauen
dass sie den Binnenmarkt mehr
zersplittern sondern allen Ländern
innerhalb der Europäischen Union helfen
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Anton Hofreiter
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ja nicht alle Länder in Europas könnten
es sich dann vielleicht leisten
entsprechende Subventionen zu verteilen
also auch die finanzschwachen müssten da
unterstützt werden sagt Anton Hofreiter
ein europäischer Rat der gigantischen
Themen die Reaktion auf die
völkerrechtswidrige Invasion Russlands
sind die Ukraine die Reaktion auf
protektionistische Maßnahmen man kann es
leider nicht anders nennen eines
wichtigen Partners und der Umgang mit
der migrationskrise bei allen drei
Themen sind die Debatten lebhaft ich
würde aber gerne zu Beginn einmal in
Erinnerung rufen dass wir jetzt knapp
ein Jahr Krieg in Europa haben und die
größte Frage die wir uns zu Beginn
gestellt haben war würde der Westen des
schaffen zusammen zu stehen und zusammen
zu bleiben und wir können nach einem
Jahr feststellen ja der Westen steht
zusammen und er bleibt zusammen wer
gestern Joe Biden
in der State of the Union Rede gehört
hat er hat gesagt wir werden die Ukraine
unterstützen as long acid takes und auch
der Europäische Rat wird am Freitag ein
Signal der Unterstützung senden so lange
wie nötig wird unterstützt wir haben
hier in Deutschland viele richtige
Entscheidungen getroffen werden Sie
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Partnern getroffen ich fand es
hervorragend dass der neue
Verteidigungsminister sofort nach Kiew
gefahren ist mit guten und wichtigen
Entscheidungen im Gepäck ich fand es
auch hervorragend dass die Europäische
Kommission zu einem großen Gipfel in
Kiel war wir müssen die Ukraine weiter
militärisch finanziell und politisch
unterstützen meine Damen und Herren
in dem Zusammenhang das will ich auch
sagen
wird ja auch ein zehntes Sanktionspaket
verabschiedet und es ärgert mich
manchmal dass ich in der deutschen
Presse Schlagzeilen lese Sanktionen
wirken nicht Krieg geht weiter oder die
russische Wirtschaft ist erstaunlich
stark obwohl wir doch die Sanktionen
haben dann liest man im Fließtext wenn
man genau hinguckt dass die russische
Wirtschaft um drei Prozent geschrumpft
ist dass die Importe nach Russland um 9%
gesunken sind dass die russische
Fluglinie Aeroflot viel längere
Lieferzeiten hat viel höhere Preise für
ihre Ersatzteile bezahlen muss dass sie
dabei ist bis zu 30% ihrer Flugzeuge
auszuschlachten und Ersatzteile zu
bekommen meine Damen und Herren
Sanktionen sind kein Lichtschalter mit
denen man kriegt an und ausknipst
Sanktionen sind ein Mittel mit dem wir
den Preis für den Krieg in die Höhe
treiben und diese geduldige Anwendung
der Sanktionen die werden wir
weitermachen weil sie die richtige
Politik ist und die Kosten für Russland
in die Höhe treibt
zum Inflation reduction Act ist
folgendes zu sagen ja der Kollege
Hofreiter hat es gerade gesagt es ist ja
gut wenn die USA Klimaschutz ernst
nehmen und etwas tun aber kooperativ ist
anders meine Damen und Herren die
beihilfepakete im Inflation reduction
Act sind so stark an nationale
Produktion gekoppelt dass das Gesetz ein
protektionistischen Charakter bekommen
hat und es ist hier gesagt worden ich
will es wiederholen hätten wir ein
Freihandelsabkommen mit den USA dann
hätten wir viele dieser Probleme die wir
jetzt haben nicht gib mir mal ganz
konkretes Beispiel Batteriehersteller
müssen mindestens 40 %. der Batterie aus
in den USA gefertigten Materialien
herstellen sonst sind sie nicht
antragsberechtigt für Beihilfen unter
diesem Gesetz das gilt aber auch für
Länder die in Freihandelsabkommen mit
den USA haben das hat die Europäische
Union nicht ich würde mir deswegen
wünschen dass wir beim Freihandel bitte
demnächst etwas konstruktiver und
produktiver und weniger auf Fake News
basieren diskutieren insbesondere wenn
es um ein Abkommen mit den USA geht
mein letzter Punkt meine Damen und
Herren migration
der Rat fordert die Kommission auf die
operativen Maßnahmen zu beschleunigen
der Rat fordert Rückübernahmeabkommen ja
auch Grenzzäune sollen gebaut werden das
soll dann auch aus europäischen Mitteln
finanziert werden die Registrierung von
ankommenden Migranten soll gesichert
werden die Visumspolitik soll gestraft
werden Hebel sollen eingesetzt werden um
Druck auszuüben man kann das alles
diskutieren das ist alles ja vielleicht
geeignet um dem Zustrom an den
Außengrenzen zu begegnen aber meine
Damen und Herren wenn man genau hinguckt
alle diese Maßnahmen sollen streng
national erfolgen es gibt in der Asyl in
der Migrationspolitik im Grenzschutz
keine europäische Zuständigkeit und wenn
man dann sich genau anschaut was der Rat
noch tut ist er ermutigt die
Mitgliedstaaten die Unterstützung der
Europäischen Union und ihre Agenturen
anzufordern das tun die Mitgliedstaaten
nämlich teilweise gar nicht
wenn man sich die Situation in
Griechenland teilweise anschaut frontext
könnte helfen wird aber von der
griechischen Regierung nicht gebeten und
deswegen meine Damen und Herren es ist
ganz klar wir müssen raus aus der
kleinen staatterei und ohne einen großen
Sprung nach vorne wird das nicht gehen
wir brauchen echte europäische
Gemeinsamkeit und das bedeutet auch eine
echte europäische Zuständigkeit auf
diesem Gebiet das für so viele
Bürgerinnen und Bürger von uns so
wichtig ist herzlichen Dank Alexander
europäischer Rat mit gigantischen Themen
das haben wir in der Aussprache ja auch
schon gemerkt Grafschaft hat noch mal
darauf Bezug genommen was Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz angekündigt hatte nämlich
neue EU-Sanktionen gegen Russland und
Grafendorf hat dafür plädiert dass man
doch bei der geduldigen Anwendung von
Sanktionen bleiben soll es ist richtig
Graf Lamsdorf es ist in der Tat positiv
erstaunlich dass die Europäische Union
nach einem Jahr Ukraine kriegt gerade
bei dem sensiblen Themen der Sanktionen
zusammengeblieben ist
das ist aber nicht das Problem das
Problem ist tatsächlich dass hier ein
Bundeskanzler sitzt der durch zögern
durch Zaudern und durch Zaghaftigkeit in
Erscheinung getreten ist und wir vieles
von dem versäumt haben was eigentlich
normal hätte sein müssen nämlich dass
wir die Ukraine von der ersten Minute an
konsequent unterstützen und es ist ja
hier die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses Frau stark
Zimmermann die ihre Koalition angehört
die sinngemäß sagt dass dieser Kanzler
im Kanzleramt sinngemäß eine
Fehlbesetzung ist dieses Zögern und
zaubern kostet Menschenleben hunderte
von Soldaten sterben jeden Tag auf
ukrainischer Seite jeden Tag in diesem
Krieg und deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass wir konsequent die Ukraine auch
entsprechend mit Waffen und mit Munition
ausstatten damit sie sich verteidigen
können damit sie das Kriegsziel auch
erreichen können auch diesen Ziel diesen
Krieg zu gewinnen
dieses Zögern und Zaudern schlägt sich
aber auch noch auf andere Ebene nieder
und das wurde wiederholt heute schon
angesprochen vor allem in Brüssel es ist
der Brandbrief von Botschafter Michael
Klaus der als Leiter der Ständigen
Vertretung in Brüssel die Interessen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland vertreten
möchte alleine er kann es nicht weil die
Ampelkoalition keinerlei abgestimmten
Positionen findet das ist das große
Problem dieses Zögern und diese
Zaghaftigkeit führt dazu und Graf
Lamsdorf weiß das als Europäer gut genug
dass wir hier nicht mit abgestimmten
Positionen in die Verhandlung gehen
können dass wir eine Europäischen
Kommission nicht sagen können was die
Position Deutschlands ist und deswegen
auch gesetzgebungsprozesse nicht
beeinflussen können das schadet
Deutschland Interessen nachhaltig und
deswegen ist es wichtig ihr eigene
Position zu finden die dann auch
orientierungsmarke sind für andere
Länder die sich natürlich sehr oft dann
auch an Deutschland ausrichten ich
möchte lobend erwähnen Herrn Habeck der
jetzt gemeinsam mit Bruno lemeer nach
Washington gereist ist ihr Bundeskanzler
hat es wohl vergessen in seiner Rede zu
erwähnen aber es ist wichtig diese
deutsch-französischen Signale zu setzen
und mit abgestimmten Positionen am
besten zwischen Deutschland und
Frankreich dann sowas auch auf
internationaler Bühne zu vertreten
deswegen es wird sich hier in Europa
nichts nach vorne bewegen wenn
Deutschland und Frankreich hier
untereinander querden Stall stehen und
keine abgestimmten Position finden ich
würde mehr letzter Satz auch wünschen
dass das noch bei der europäischen
politischen Gemeinschaft in Zukunft der
Fall ist denn hier brauchen wir ein
Modell das gerade Staaten wieder Ukraine
ist dann auch in Zukunft erlauben
assoziierte Mitglieder bereits sein zu
können bevor sie endgültig Mitglieder
werden können denn das wird Jahre dauern
auch für die Balkanstaaten herzlichen
Dank vielen Dank
nächster Rednerin ist die Kollegin Lena
Werner SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen seit der russischen Invasion
der Ukraine vor fast einem Jahr befinden
wir uns in Europa und der Welt in einer
Ausnahmesituation
diese Zeitenwende hat uns alle
vorausforderungen gestellt in dieser
Zeit war und ist es unerlässlich dass
wir zusammen mit unseren europäischen
Partnern handeln und uns den
Herausforderungen gemeinsam stellen und
die Transformation der Wirtschaft
gemeinsam weiter vorantreiben
der russische Angriffskrieg hat die
tiefgreifenden Auswirkungen auf unser
Wirtschaftssystem und die
Energiesicherheit Europas und der Welt
man kann sich unsere Wirtschaft wie ein
Haus vorstellen dieses Haus steht auf
einem soliden Fundament aber wir haben
es in den letzten Jahren immer weiter
mit günstigen russischen Gas als
Bausubstanz nach oben ausgebaut diese
Bausubstanz ist jetzt marode geworden
und muss erneuert werden deswegen waren
die EU die Bundesregierung und wir als
Parlament gefragt zu sanieren und eine
neue Bausubstanz zu beschaffen um unser
Haus also die deutsche und europäische
Wirtschaft zu stabilisieren
die neue Substanz besteht zu einem
großen Teil aus den Entlastungen die die
Bundesregierung für Privatpersonen kamus
und die Industrie geschaffen hat nämlich
die Mittel aus dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds die
energiepreisbremsen härtefallfonds und
Einmalzahlungen und auch die EU wird mit
der europäischen industriestrategie zur
Stabilisierung dieser Substanz beitragen
da begrüßen wir das nicht dass die nicht
abgerufenen Gelder aus dem next
generation eu-front umgewidmet und zur
Förderung einer wettbewerbsfähigen und
nachhaltigen Industrie investiert werden
gleichzeitig brauchen wir aber auch ein
Update des europäischen beihilferechts
Bürokratieabbau und schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren
die Krisen unserer Zeit zeigen deutlich
dass wir nur gemeinsam stark sind da
sind Handels- und rohstoff-
wir müssen uns im Handel unabhängiger
von Autokratien machen aber gleichzeitig
auf einen freien und fairen handelsätzen
und wie der Bundeskanzler vorhin schon
richtig gesagt hat brauchen wir keinen
subventions-gänge wir brauchen eine enge
Zusammenarbeit der Volkswirtschaften um
gegen die größte Bedrohung der
Menschheit zu kämpfen die sich immer
weiter verschärfende Klimakatastrophe
wir brauchen ein geeintes globales
handeln und deswegen begrüßen wir
grundsätzlich dass die USA mit dem
Inflation reduction Act nun endlich den
Weg zur Klimaneutralität und der
Verringerung von CO2-Ausstoß
eingeschlagen haben allerdings müssen
wir beim Inflation reduction Act genau
hinschauen das haben wir als auch schon
heute öfter gehört und dafür sorgen dass
europäische Unternehmen durch diesen
nicht benachteiligt werden
gleichzeitig dürfen wir an dieser Stelle
aber nicht vergessen dass die
Europäische Union bereits jetzt schon
einen Wegweiser hin zu einer
nachhaltigen Transformation der
Industrie ist wir haben eine
Vorreiterrolle und investieren bereits
seit einigen Jahren in diese
Transformation wir waren und sind trotz
hohen Energiepreisen weiterhin
konkurrenzfähig gewesen
und vor allem unsere Gesellschaft ist in
großen Teilen darauf eingestellt und hat
ein Bewusstsein für die nachhaltige
Entwicklung und unseres Landes und dass
der EU all diese Maßnahme in Summe
bilden dieses starke Fundament und das
Gerüst für das Haus unserer Wirtschaft
das mit dem Handeln der EU und der
Bundesregierung jetzt saniert und
monatisiert werden muss blicken wir nun
vor diesem Hintergrund auf die USA so
wird den Flächen redakt wie ein Gebäude
auf einem sandigen Boden denn der ist im
Vergleich zur EU die erste wirklich der
erste wirkliche Ansatz für eine
nachhaltige Transformation der
US-amerikanischen Wirtschaft
der Wandel kann nicht übers Bein
gebrochen werden wir haben unsere
Transformation auf ein starkes Fundament
gestellt wie bei einem professionellen
Hausbau üblich denn das Fundament ist
essentiell die USA hingegen fangen
direkt mit dem mittleren Stockwerk an
klar ist wir sind eine starke
Volkswirtschaft und brauchen uns nicht
vor dem Inflation reduction Act
ängstigen zu lassen und zu verstecken
was wir uns allerdings von den USA ab
können abgucken können ist deren
Pragmatismus und dass wir diesen in uns
haben haben wir in diesen Kriegen Krisen
eindeutig gezeigt jetzt müssen wir uns
nur noch trauen ihn regelmäßig weiter
einzusetzen vielen Dank
vielen Dank war das für die SPD-Fraktion
ja der Inflation Redaktion Akte also
jenes 370 Milliarden Dollar
Subventionsprogramm der USA für grüne
Technologien darauf will die EU auch auf
diesem Sondergipfel eine Antwort finden
die kommissionspräsidentin hatte
Vorschläge dazu schon mal vorbereitet
und vorgelegte Robin wahrgenommen
als ich Millionen Ukrainerinnen und
Ukraine gegen die Abwendung von Europa
Willkürherrschaft und Korruption
stellten kam es von neun Jahren zur
Revolution der würde und diesen
Freiheitsdrang konnte weder die damalige
ukrainische Regierung mit Spezialkräften
noch putinsoldaten mit Gewalt brechen
für diese beeindruckende
Entschlossenheit zahlt die Ukraine seit
2014 bis heute ein sehr hohen Preis
bis heute auf Putin auf eine Schwächung
der Unterstützung unseres Bündnisses
aber Diktator Putin hat sich in
ideologischer Verblendung geirrt wir
stehen fest an der Seite der Ukraine und
das nicht nur als einzelne Staaten auch
die Europäische Union als ein
Zusammenschluss freier Demokratien in
Vielfalt der Stärke durch Reduzierung
individueller macht erreicht steht fest
an der Seite der Ukraine ein Konzept das
Putin nie verstanden hat dessen
Strahlkraft aber heute durch den mutigen
Kampf der Ukraine noch deutlicher
hervortritt
die Bilder vom EU Ukraine gibt für
letzte Woche mit Präsident selenski
kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen der
gesamten ukrainischen Regierung und 15
Kommissarinnen und Kommissaren senden
einen eindrucksvolles Signal der
Solidarität
inmitten des Krieges strebt die Ukraine
entschlossen in die EU vergangene Woche
sagte unsere Vizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt in Kiews so passend die
Ukraine gehört zur europäischen Familie
es geht nicht mehr um das Ob sondern das
wie das EU-Beitritts und dennoch bleibt
einiges zu tun Reformen sind in Zeiten
des Krieges besonders schwierig aber
dennoch unerlässlich und gerade
Dezentralisierung eine starke
Zivilgesellschaft ein selbstbewusstes
und gestaltendes Parlament sind jetzt
wichtig für den Weg in die EU die
Bedingungen sind klar benannt und
natürlich dauert der Weg aber um ihn so
schnell wie möglich zu gehen verdienen
die Menschen in der Ukraine alle unsere
Unterstützung diesen Weg mit voller
Kraft zu gehen
und auch wenn es hier um die Erklärung
der Bundesregierung geht ich finde auch
wir als Parlament können unseren Beitrag
dazu leisten und deswegen werde ich auch
dafür dass wir neben den Aktivitäten die
die Parlamentariergruppe hat auf allen
Ebenen und auch auf den Ausschüssen die
interparlamentarische Zusammenarbeit mit
der Ukraine immer weiter stärken denn
wir können gut gegen miteinander
voneinander lernen und dabei die Ukraine
auf dem schnellen Weg in die Europäische
Union unterstützen
mit Blick auf den traurigen jahrestag
des Angriffskrieges müssen wir auch die
Planungen zum Wiederaufbau beschleunigen
wir müssen Mechanismen schaffen damit
Russland und seine Führung für die
ungeheuren Kriegsverbrechen zur
Verantwortung gezogen wird und
gleichzeitig müssen wir die Kosten
Russlands für diesen Krieg weiter
erhöhen und das heißt neben dem
Schließen von sanktionslücken ist es
auch an der Zeit endlich den
uranax-export und Wasserturm zu
sanktionieren
auf dem Maidan dem Unabhängigkeitsplatz
in Kiew skandierten die mutigen
Studierenden bereits 2013 Ukrainer Cobra
die Ukraine ist Europa 9 Jahre später
gilt das mehr denn je vielen dank vielen
Dank Kollege
hält das Wort der fraktionsweise
Abgeordnete robertale
der Bundestag hatte derzeit sechs
fraktionslose Abgeordnete einer davon
der mal für die AFD hier in den
Bundestag eingezogen ist die nicht mehr
Mitglied der Fraktion ist hat jetzt das
Rederecht als fraktionsloser robertal
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
mittlerweile hat die US-Regierung ihre
Kriegsziele in ihrem Stellvertreter
Krieg in der Ukraine im Wesentlichen
erreicht
sie hat mit der Zerstörung der
nordstream-pipelines erreicht dass
unsere energetische Basis in Deutschland
weitgehend ruiniert ist und wir
Wettbewerbsnachteile gegenüber den USA
haben so dass die USA jetzt Teile
unserer Wirtschaft mit der Verlockung
von preiswerter Energie in den USA
abwerben kann sie haben ihr Ziel
erreicht dass die us-rüstungsindustrie
nun mehr für viele Jahre boomen wird
Blackrock ist bereits in das Geschäft
mit dem Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
eingestiegen wobei dafür die 300
Milliarden Dollar gestohlen hatte
wiesenreserven aus Russland eingesetzt
werden sollen den Zugriff auf die
wichtigsten Agrarflächen und
Rohstoffvorkommen haben sie
US-Investoren bereits längst gesichert
es gab schon im April einen Vorschlag
für einen Waffenstillstand dann hätte es
diesen ganzen Krieg nie gegeben den
Chancen im Auftrag der NATO verhindert
diesen Waffenstillstand und dieses
Abkommen darum gibt es diesen Krieg
jetzt ist die USA aber bereit zu einem
Friedensvorschlag der Vorschlag ist von
der Grand Corporation gekommen der
Inhalt lautet die russischen
Sicherheitsinteressen sollen jetzt
berücksichtigt werden und die Ukraine
soll aufgeteilt werden ca 20 Prozent
ihres ehemaligen Staatsgebiets aufgeben
gegen
Sicherheitsgarantien die man vereinbaren
soll eine NATO-Mitgliedschaft soll es
nicht geben und was tut sehr linski
jetzt er lehnt weiterverhandlungen ab er
fordert Atomwaffen für die Ukraine als
Sicherheit für sich er will nach wie vor
die Krim erobern und er will den
dornwasserobern und alle
militärspezialisten wissen dass das
unmöglich ist gegen eine atomacht wenn
wir alle nicht wollen dass wir nuklearen
Untergang reingezogen werden dann muss
selensky gestoppt werden ich fordere
kein Geld für die Ukraine so lange wie
die Ukraine keine Friedensverhandlungen
durchführt keine Waffenlieferung in
Ukraine solange es keine
Waffenstillstandsverhandlungen
ist viel schlauer als viele in diesem
Haus der weiß dass ein friedensklub was
bringt das andere bringt nichts vielen
Dank
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Fabian Funke
erst Mitglied im Europaausschuss des
Bundestages für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren wir kommen von den
Absurditäten und
verschwörungserzählungen wieder zurück
zu dem wirklich ernsthaften Thema des
Europäischen Rates denn der hat
schwierige Fragen mit unterschiedlichen
Positionen der Mitgliedstaaten zu klären
morgen doch bei allen politischen
inhaltlichen und zum Teil auch ganz
grundsätzlichen
Meinungsverschiedenheiten in anderen
Politikfeldern gilt die Europäische
Union steht geschlossen und entschlossen
an der Seite der Ukraine und das haben
wir in den letzten Monaten ja nicht nur
mit großen Sprüchen gemacht sondern in
Tat umgesetzt mit großer militärischer
und auch humanitäre Unterstützung der
Ukraine mit dem Schmieden von Koalition
auch insbesondere unter der Führung der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und auch mit
einem Fahrplan für eine glaubhafte
europäische Perspektive der Ukraine der
zweite große Punkt auf der Agenda ist
die Zukunftsfähigkeit unserer
europäischen Wirtschaft und die
europäische ische Antwort auf den irony
dazu haben wir bereits heute einiges
gehört und da möchte ich ganz klar sagen
insbesondere aus der rechten Ecke dieser
Anti-Amerikanismus und der Kniefall vor
Russland wird uns nicht helfen
die Kommission hat Vorschläge gemacht
und die sind gut jetzt geht es darum die
so auszudefinieren dass wir die
europäische Wirtschaft stärken und
weiter zukunftsfähig in ihrer grünen
Transformation machen und dann werden
wir langfristig natürlich auch noch mal
über die Frage der Finanzierung der
Europäischen Union reden müssen das ist
völlig klar die dritte Säule des
ratsgipfels ist die europäische
Migrationspolitik und wenn wir ehrlich
sind kein Thema in denen es in den
letzten Jahren wirklich fortschritte gab
und bei dem auch keine großen
attack-lösungen absehbar sind die
Konstellation im Rat dazu ist nicht
einfach die einen würden gerne tausende
Kilometer Grenzzäune errichten die
anderen verweisen fortwährend auf die
Umsetzung von Dublin 2 und währenddessen
bleibt es im Mittelmeer beim grausamen
Status Quo ich bin deshalb dankbar dass
der Bundeskanzler trotz dieser
schwierigen Umstände das Thema nicht
aufgibt und darauf besteht gemeinsame
Lösungen zu finden
denn was passiert eigentlich wenn wir
die Frage der Einwanderungspolitik immer
weiter verschleppen was passiert wenn
Europa sich weiterhin auf Jahre von
nationalistischen Kräften lähmen lässt
wir haben heute viel diskutiert über die
europäische Wirtschaft wie wir sie
zukunftsfest gestalten dass die
zeitenwände auch vor unserer Industrie
nicht Halt macht die Wahrheit ist doch
die europäische Industrie befindet sich
bereits seit einiger Zeit mitten in
einem Umbruch der Umbruch unserer
gesellschaftlichen Altersstruktur der
Bundeskanzler wird nicht müde ist zu
betonen alleine in Deutschland brauchen
wir in den nächsten Jahren Zuwanderung
von Millionen von Menschen um unseren
Wohlstand zu halten um offene Stellen zu
füllen um unsere Sozialsysteme und
Steuereinnahmen stabil zu halten und
auch weiterhin ein attraktiver Standort
für Spitzenforschung Investitionen und
Zukunftstechnologien zu sein
in anderen europäischen Ländern sieht
das nicht anders aus die Wahrheit ist
die Blockade einer kohärenten und
humanen europäischen Migrationspolitik
ist langfristig schädlicher für den
Wohlstand in Deutschland und Europa als
es jede Energiekrise oder Pandemie je
sein könnten und dass sie liebe Union im
Vorfeld jeder Wahl in Hoffnung auf ein
paar Wählerstimmen wieder die
resortiments gegen Migrantinnen und
Migranten aus der Mottenkiste holen dass
sie in gute und schlechte Migration
unterscheiden und jetzt sogar auf
europäischer Ebene Rechtsaußenparteien
Umgang in dem Versuch ihre Chancen für
den weil Sieg bei der Europawahl zu
erhöhen zeigt doch einfach dass sie in
diesen Fragen absolut nichts verstanden
haben
Migration ist ein Fakt sie passiert ob
sie es wollen oder nicht Migration
stellt uns natürlich vorher
Herausforderungen allerdings stärkt sie
uns auch kulturell wirtschaftlich und
auch als ganze Gesellschaft und wir
haben eine humanitäre Verantwortung
schon Migration menschenwürdig und legal
aber eben auch geordnet zu ermöglichen
egal auf dem Mittelmeer an der Grenze zu
Belarus oder an der Grenze zur Türkei
deshalb ist es gut dass der Kanzler und
auch bundesinnenministerin Nancy fazer
trotz der eher dürftigen politischen
Ausgangslage den europäischen
migrationspakt nicht aufgeben und darauf
bestehen die Dossiers weiter zu
verhandeln und deshalb ist es richtig
dass der Bundeskanzler beim Rad
Klarstellung bezieht dass wir neben
vielen anderen Dingen auch die Schaffung
legaler migrationswege brauchen und
diese zwangsläufig Teil einer
europäischen Lösung sein müssen man kann
ihm dabei nur gutes Gelingen wünschen
vielen Dank
ja wie diese europäische Lösung aussehen
soll beim Thema Migration das bleibt
auch vor diesem Gipfel die ganz große
Frage den vor dem Gipfel machen
Österreich und sieben weitere Staaten
Druck für höhere Hürden beim Thema
Zuwanderung es geht um mehr EU
finanzierte Maßnahmen zum Schutz der
Außengrenzen beispielsweise und raschere
Abschiebung Nina Schere jetzt für die
Sozialdemokraten nächste Rednerin
und Kollegen ich möchte auch kurz
aufgreifen das womit mein Kollege mein
Vorredner geschlossen hat die
Migrationsfragen die er einen großen
Teil der anstehenden Verhandlungen beim
Europäischen Rat sein werden und ich
finde das zutiefst irritierend Herr Merz
und auch das was von anderen Rednern
ihrer aus ihren Reihen kamen wie sie nun
die aktuelle die aktuellen Anlässe über
Migration sich auf europäischer Ebene zu
verständigen erneut zu verständigen
Kanzler Olaf Scholz hat es ausgeführt
wir haben die größte Fluchtbewegung seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg dass sie dies in
einer Weise hier debattiert haben wollen
womit
Ängste wiederum geführt werden
ungeordnetheit Innenraum gestellt wird
vermeintliche ungeordnetheit von
Migration dass dies alles etwas nicht
gut gehändeltes sein dass dies alles
etwas der Politik entgleitendes sei und
damit machen sie den Menschen Angst und
damit bedienen Sie genau diese
Restaurants die auch immer vom rechten
Rand kommen und das hätte ich mir
wirklich anders gewünscht aus ihrem
Reich
es ist
es ist zudem auch wirtschaftspolitisch
höchst fragwürdig sie haben wörtlich
gerade ausgeführt dass man erstmal den
heimischen Arbeitsmarkt ausschöpfen
solle es ist längst bekannt dass wir auf
dem heimischen Arbeitsmarkt zu wenig
Arbeitskräfte haben mit den großen auf
Anforderungen die wir haben auch um die
Klimakatastrophe abzuwenden um die
Transformation hinzubekommen ist es
unabwendbar auch als Einwanderungsland
ein klares Bekenntnis zu geben und
natürlich dann die Integrationsaufgaben
zu leisten das ist unsere Aufgabe aber
doch nicht eine Fokussierung auf Deutsch
ständige beim Arbeitsmarkt das ist
wirklich nicht das richtige Thema da
haben sie das Thema verfehlt und ich
finde auch
die Vorzeichen von Humanität und
Menschenrechten ganz bei the way auch
außer Acht gelassen wenn ich wieder
zurückkomme auf die Aufgaben die vom
Europäischen Rat zu leisten sein werden
das zweite große Kapitel was ebenfalls
jetzt ansteht ist in der Tat dass wir
eine Antwort oder ein Umgang mit dem
Inflation Redaktion Act finden und es
ist auch hier richtig
einmal voran zu stellen dass es ein
Riesenfortschritt ist wenn die
Vereinigten Staaten geschafft haben
diese Klippe zu überspringen die sie
lange nicht übersprungen haben mit Trump
war das ja undenkbar dass Sie erkannt
haben wir brauchen weltweit alle Kräfte
um den Klimawandel zu aufzuhalten um ihn
zu stoppen und tatsächlich hier auch die
Energiewende zu finanzieren finanziert
zu bekommen alle Kräfte zu mobilisieren
das ist ja erstmal der Impuls der hinter
dem Inflation steht und insofern muss
man sagen das ist richtig
zum anderen müssen wir aber natürlich
schauen dass dies auch wettbewerbliche
Situationen auslöst dass dies gerade in
Zeiten von Fachkräftemangel in Europa
und insbesondere auch in Deutschland
Folgewirkungen und folgeaufgaben nach
sich zieht den wir uns stellen müssen
und wir haben leider in den letzten 20
Jahren ich sage mal 16 Jahren 17 Jahren
in den Endphasen der großen Koalition
gab es schon einen leichten Wandel zum
Besseren aber wir hatten leider eine
restriktive Politik der Energiewende
auch hier in Deutschland da hat ihre
Fraktion Herr März cdu/cs Fraktion eine
ganz entscheidende Bremse immer gehabt
das ist zum Glück jetzt überwunden aber
das hat natürlich uns kostbare Jahre
gekostet
dieser aufwuchspart den wir zunächst
hatten aus Deutschland heraus die
Energiewende anzugehen es war weltweit
etwas nachgefragtes geworden die
Unternehmen sind dann leider ja auch
abgewandert deswegen haben wir eine
Importabhängigkeit von 90 Prozent bei
den bei der Solarindustrie in
Deutschland heute das hätte anders
laufen müssen da sind wir jetzt dabei
diesen diesen Pfad einzuschlagen wieder
zurückzugewinnen hier wieder die
vorreiterschaften zu übernehmen und
Deutschland und Europa hier wirklich zum
Bollwerk das Transformationsprozesses zu
machen um tatsächlich die Energiewende
hier in der gebotenen Zeit hinzubekommen
und dafür brauchen wir natürlich
europäische Verständigung darauf wie wir
Beihilfe rechtliche Vorgaben so anpassen
können dass dieser Kraftakt zu leisten
ist das Garantien abgegeben werden
können das auch die aufbauung Resilienz
faszinität von der Europa so genutzt
werden kann dass sie uns in
Transformationsprozess hilft dass wir
etwa die Notfall Verordnung jetzt
schnell umgesetzt bekommen weil sie gilt
nur 18 Monate da sind wir gerade unter
Hochdruck dabei dies hinzubekommen und
all diese Dinge brauchen wir um eine ein
Umgang mit dem Inflation redakt zu
bekommen dann ist der
Transformationsprozess gut zu leisten
und in diesem Sinne packen
die Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und
Energie der SPD-Fraktion jetzt hören wir
erneut einen fraktions-
das wird sein Johannes Huber
liebe Mitbürger sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin mit ihrer Genehmigung ein
Zitat zu beginnen das Hauptinteresse der
Vereinigten Staaten wofür wir über einen
jahrhundert Kriege führten erste Zweite
Weltkrieg und Karl der Krieg waren die
Beziehungen zwischen Deutschland und
Russland weil vereint sie die einzige
Macht sind die uns bedrohen kann wer
sagt das George Friedman der Gründer der
privaten Schatten CIA ist Red vor
spätestens seit dem Angriffskrieg von
Putin gegen den gegenstrategischen
Pufferstaat Ukraine ist aber auch klar
dass Putin Interessen nicht mit den
deutschen Sicherheitsinteressen eine
souveränen Polen sind auch einer
souveränen Ukraine vereinbar sind im
deutschen Interesse besteht viel mehr
Frieden und Vermittlung die Ablehnung
des amerikanischen Friedens
vorschlagenes 20% Land gegen Frieden
seitens der Ukraine und Putin die
gratuliert den Westen jetzt aber
zugunsten der verbliebenen Vermittler
der Türkei und Ungarn
die Ablehnung zeigt auch insbesondere
dass sich die Lage seit dem ersten
Rammstein treffen um 180 Grad gedreht
hat Weisheit dem vor allem die Strategie
der USA und Großbritannien den Krieg zu
verlängern um Russland maximal zu
schwächen so ist es jetzt leider vor
allem putinsziel den Krieg weiter zu
verlängern und den Westen weiter zu
schwächen
wenn Deutschland also diesen zweiten
Kalten Krieg muss man leider sagen der
dank der deutschen Außenministerin
jederzeit zum dritten Weltkrieg werden
kann nicht verlieren will dann müssen
wir mit einer schnellstmöglichen
Auflistung der
bundeswehrsicherheitspolitisch
unabhängig werden eigenes gasfördern das
grundlastfähige Stromangebot nicht
weiter verknappen sondern vergrößern die
Industrie in Sachen Rohstoffe
unabhängiger von einzelnen Lieferanten
machen die Bevölkerung bei Lebensmitteln
und Medikamenten autark werden und die
europäischen Banken müssen vor der
kommenden Schuldenkrise dass sie
abzeichnet ihr Eigenkapital erhöhen das
wären zumindest die erste Schritte zu
einer stärkeren Position Deutschlands
und Europas vielen Dank
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion
Johannes Schraps und das wird auch der
letzte Redner sein in der Aussprache zur
Regierungserklärung von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz also Johannes strafs für die
SPD hier mit dem letzten Wort
verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zum Glück gab
es anders als die Worte meines
Vorredners heute sehr viele Redebeiträge
die der Tragweite und der Themen die wir
heute diskutieren zumindest überwiegend
gerecht wurden und zum Ende der Debatte
können wir denke ich auch feststellen
eines ganz klar feststellen an
drängenden Themen mangelt es uns hier im
Haus und mangelt es auch den
regierungschefinnen und Regierungschefs
morgen beim Europäischen Rat in Brüssel
definitiv nicht die notwendige
Unterstützung der Ukraine die
Modernisierung und Stärkung des
europäischen Binnenmarktes und
Fortschritte bei der europäischen
Migrationspolitik und leider das ist zu
Beginn der Debatte genannt worden auch
mit Blick auf das verheerende Erdbeben
in der Türkei und die notwendigen
schnellen Hilfsmaßnahmen ist noch ein
weiteres Thema hinzugekommen eine lange
Länder und viele Themen und persönlich
würde ich mir wünschen wenn bei all dem
auch die Situation im Iran nicht ganz
aus dem Blick gerät und es zumindest am
Rande der offiziellen Agenda Gespräche
gibt wie die Menschen die sich für eine
demokratische Zukunft des Iran einsetzen
noch besser in ihrem Freiheitskampf
unterstützt werden könnten denn der Iran
das ist ein schlüsselstaat dessen
demokratische Entwicklung großen
Einfluss auf zahlreiche andere
konfliktäre in der Region hätte bei den
vielen Themen ist insbesondere mit Blick
auf die Ukraine die Entschlossenheit und
die Geschlossenheit der Europäischen
Union und unser transatlantischen
Partner ganz sicher ein entscheidender
Faktor und Olaf Scholz hat die drei
Grundprinzipien die unser Handeln bei
der Unterstützung der Ukraine prägen
heute dankenswerterweise noch mal
deutlich genannt wenn ich hier Aussagen
höre wie der Kanzler müsste Vertrauen
bei den EU-Partnern zurückgewinnen dann
kann ich nur mit dem Kopf schütteln ich
bin als Mitglied des europaausschusses
und im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
sehr viel mit unseren Partnerinnen und
Partnern im Gespräch und deren Vertrauen
ist groß verehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
von Delegationen aus den Partnerländern
die nach Berlin kommen ebenso wie bei
unseren Besuchen bei anderen
befreundeten Partnerinnen und Partnern
damit immer wieder der Wunsch nach
Führungsstärke von Seiten der
Bundesregierung geäußert und zwar
vollkommen zu Recht weil man das von
einem in vielerlei Hinsicht starken Land
wie dem unsere Regen das in der Mitte
Europas liegt eben auch erwarten kann
aber genauso häufig wird darauf
hingewiesen dass die Partner mitgenommen
werden wollen und wie wichtig es ist
weitsichtig und wohl abgewogen zu
handeln und Dinge gemeinsam zu tun und
das ist eben der Balanceakt zwischen
Verantwortung und Führung übernehmen und
vorangehen und gleichzeitig die Partner
mitnehmen und nicht durch ein eventuell
über altes und unbedachtes vorbrechen zu
überfahren
und deshalb ist es für unsere Partnerin
und Partner sicherlich immer wieder
wichtig und beruhigend zu hören wenn sie
bei Olaf Scholz eine klare und
konsistente Haltung erkennen und wenn er
sagt ich wäre weiter ab und ich werde
mich auch in Zukunft eng mit unseren
Partnern abstimmen richtig so liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und dieses ständige Gerede von Zögern
und Zaudern wird auch durch mehrfache
Wiederholung von Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus CDU und CSU wirklich nicht
richtiger denn egal wie oft die Herren
März Dobrindt oder leider eben auch
Kriechbaum versuchen einen anderes ein
falsches Bild zu zeichnen es ist doch
anders das erfolgreiche Werben des
Kanzlers für Allianzen hat viel mehr
gezeigt dass die Europäische Union auch
in schwierigen auch in komplexen
Situationen letztlich zu gemeinsamen
Handeln fähig ist verehrte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und das ist wichtig
und abschließend möchte ich noch ein
Wort zu dem verheerenden Erdbeben in der
Türkei loswerden denn wir leiden in der
Tat mit wenn wir uns die schrecklichen
Bilder der Erdbebenkatastrophe in der
Türkei und in Syrien anschauen müssen
man kann nur mitleiden wenn man diese
Bilder sieht aber wir müssen sie nur am
Fernseher oder über andere Medienkanäle
verfolgen viele von denen die
glücklicherweise nicht verschüttet
worden sind müssen in eisiger Kälte
aussachen und deshalb ist es wichtig
dass Olaf Scholz den Betroffenen im
Namen unseres Landes schnelle Hilfe
zugesagt hat und dass wir auch sehr
schnell hilfe losgeschickt haben und
auch weiter so gut es geht unterstützen
verehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
habe zu Beginn noch mal kurz genannt wie
viele drängende Themen auf der Agenda
des Gipfel stehen es ist gut dass wir
heute die Leitplanken in der
Regierungserklärung noch mal gehört
haben und in diesem Sinne hoffe ich auf
einen erfolgreichen und produktiven
EU-Gipfel und bedanke mich herzlich für
die Aufmerksamkeit der sagt Johannes
Straps für die SPD hier zum Abschluss
dieser Debatte und zu diesem Gipfel wird
der Bundeskanzler der den Auftrag
gemacht hat mit dieser
Regierungserklärungen morgen und
übermorgen Reisen zum
EU-Sondergipfel mit einem sehr großen
und schwierigen Themen dafür